It's like, I don't, I really don't know.
I want you to just party.
Get in your groove, party.
If they start to counter you, then you play.
Like, you know, it's more serious.
That's it.
Your party mode is too much for everyone to handle.
You've been partying, it's been working.
Let's keep the party going.
She could have done the...
She could have just been doing running grab the entire slam if she kept doing rank, though.
No, that's not true.
No, I would have.
No, what do you mean?
Yeah, that's the one thing that's not working.
Every match, does she know?
Do they know?
And then she just runs at them.
Oh yeah, it's like a check.
But I think by now they might know.
I think they know now.
I think they all know.
If she didn't do dedicated stuff, she would have still been doing that.
Yeah.
I wish they would have stopped knowing.
What team is Serratina on?
The one that you were like...
Auto.
Automatic.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's the same as the Roy team.
That's Roy's team.
Yeah, that's your inner demon right there.
Yeah.
Your inner demon.
Yeah, I know.
Jamie is such a weird man.
What I do, like I was playing a bunch of Jamie's on rank two.
Yeah.
It's just like, they love to back up.
They love backing up.
They hardly crouch.
Yeah, they want to randomly drive rush in.
They back up to make space.
With that three hit punch, they drive rush in.
The heavy punch.
Yeah.
Or they back up fishing for the poke.
Or if that doesn't work, then they randomly drive rush in.
And if you don't approach, they just keep getting...
Drunk.
Yeah.
It's rough.
I bet that that matchup is kind of...
Oh, she's giving me player one.
Oh, that's sick.
Ow.
Oh, she didn't...
Wait, she's still typing.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I doubt Gumi is nice like that.
Oh, no.
Oh, damn it.
I got it.
I mean, she woke up and chose violence, bro.
All right, let's go.
Oh, she's going in?
Okay, cool.
Cool.
All right, squad.
All right, let's do it.
Let's go, Doki.
It begins.
Oh, no.
No.
I really have to go to the back.
I'm going.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
You got this.
Oh, Doki.
Let's go.
Oh, no.
She's...
Okay.
Yep.
She's playing very passive.
She will.
But that's all right.
Nice.
Triangle.
Yep.
Nice.
Nice, Larry.
Oh.
Oh, I love the idea, though.
But you're good.
You're good.
Oh.
Nice.
Yes.
Oh.
Okay.
Go, Doki.
Go.
Nice.
Good job.
Yeah.
That was the feeler round.
You're feeling it out.
I think she was feeling me out, too.
Mm-hmm.
Like, she is, like...
She's kind of spooked.
She's playing super different.
She's scared, but...
Yeah.
But that's okay.
That's normal.
Oh.
Okay.
One of those is no problem.
Nice.
Keep approaching.
Yep.
Oh.
Nice.
Retaliation.
Okay.
Level three on the table.
Oh.
Keep walking towards her.
Walk and block.
That's fine.
Oh.
She's doing a lot of anti-airs, what I've noticed.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, no.
Nice jump.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
Nice.
That was sick.
Oh.
That's fine.
Good block.
Yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
Let's go.
That was so solid, Doki.
Nice block, Doki.
Doki.
Well played.
Nice.
That was clean.
And the neutral game was on point.
Yeah.
I love it.
She's so...
She's playing really, really different.
So I'm like not...
Yeah.
We trained for this.
You got it.
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
We take those.
Where are we at?
Oh, Doki won.
Let's go, baby.
Aw.
That's cool.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, I jumped that too.
Nice jump over.
Yeah.
Just keep walking towards her.
This is neutral.
Oops.
That was an accident.
She hit that first?
Oh.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
That was...
That was a low.
Good idea.
Yeah.
Just keep approaching her.
Make sure to keep moving forward.
And then you...
If you get closer, you can jump.
But just keep trying to bulldog your way closer.
Okay.
Yeah.
It...
She's going to move on wake up.
Okay.
Just block after she wakes up.
Yeah.
I understand now.
Yep.
Nice block.
Keep moving towards her.
Nice.
Three.
Oh.
Save that meter.
Yeah, on us.
Yeah.
Watch your meter.
Okay.
You're still in it.
Nice.
One more.
Is he jump?
Oh.
That thing.
That's fine.
You are still in it.
Guys, we are alive.
Guys, we are still in it.
We are alive.
Oh.
Nice.
That was great.
Unlucky.
Awww.
That's fine.
So Doki, you gotta make sure that you're not just walking back and forth from fullscreen.
You need to always be walking forward block.
You gotta get closer to her.
So even though she might threaten these random moves, while you're thinking about them and defending, you just gotta keep moving in to party.
And then just let her wake up here.
Okay.
There you go.
Her little fullscreen moves do way less damage than one of your grabs, so don't sweat it if you get hit by them.
Yeah, just keep bulldogging your way in.
Walk and block and get in.
There you go.
It's fine.
Just do it again.
Nice.
There you go.
You gotta save your meter.
That's fine.
Nice!
Nice throw.
Okay.
Let's go!
See?
Yeah, just keep approaching.
Don't be scared to keep walking towards her.
Oh my goodness.
Let's go.
Okay.
Okay, just watch your meter for a little while.
Nice.
Aww.
I have a feeling she's gonna do that too.
No worries.
Keep walking towards her.
Nice.
Yep.
Keep walking towards her.
Nice.
Did she hit me first?
No.
You got her.
Aww.
Oh, too close.
I'm terrified.
Doki, level three on the table.
You got level three?
You got it.
Mm-hmm.
You got it, Doki.
Let's go.
Just keep doing what you're doing.
Wait.
No!
Oh, no!
That was an accident!
It's fine.
That wasn't even...
I didn't mean to press that.
Just chill.
That was so unlucky.
I, like, back-fingered it too.
No, you're in the game.
It's done.
Nice.
Good.
Wow.
Get in there.
Nice.
One more, Doki.
One more.
She's scared.
That's fine.
You're good.
Wait.
Does that kill me?
No.
Oh, maybe.
It's close.
Actually, it might.
I mean, it kills me.
It's close.
Just focus.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Focus.
No!
I jumped!
I jumped, too.
Nice try.
It was, like, down to the wire.
Yeah.
Down to the wire.
I even pressed jump.
Yeah.
I saw it either way.
Good try.
Good try, Doki.
That was a good fight.
I enjoyed that thoroughly.
Great fight.
I enjoyed that.
I didn't fat finger my level three.
That was, like, yeah.
Yeah.
All right.
Because I pressed lariat, and then it hit my level three for some reason.
Let's do this.
All right, SK.
Let's game.
Yo, yo, yo, yo.
Confidence.
Have confidence.
Okay.
I never get nervous in Overwatch.
So weird.
Because you have four other people on the squad, maybe.
I don't know.
Yeah, probably.
All right, SK.
Let's play a game.
And 15,000 hours.
Play your game.
Just do your best.
Whatever happens.
Like, I mean, we still love you, right?
It doesn't matter.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
Play your game.
Let's go, SK.
Oh,
nice.
Uh -oh.
It's fine.
Just chill.
Yeah.
Just gotta chill.
Nice grab.
Nice.
There we go.
Good offense.
Oh, nice offense.
Yeah.
He just...
He randomly DI's always.
Oh.
It's okay.
Hey.
Yeah.
Just block it out.
That's fine.
Block.
Nice block.
Punish.
Oh.
Okay.
That's good.
We're good.
Yeah.
If you block that, you can dash up punish.
But you're good.
You're playing great.
Gotcha.
Nice combo.
Yep.
All right.
That's fine.
Yeah.
We block and wake up.
Where you going?
Yeah.
Take this.
Good punish.
Nice punish.
Nice.
Ooh.
That was a good idea.
What?
A stare down.
Yeah.
That was funny.
Nice.
No.
Aw.
That's close.
That's cool.
Remember.
Yeah.
You know how to play against him.
He just mashes DI.
And now...
And when he's cornered, he'll DP.
I feel like you can bait it out.
At least once.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah.
Don't...
What's...
You got it.
Okay.
He keeps throwing.
And you never...
Ow.
He just...
He never presses anything.
Yeah.
Just...
Just medium...
Just do medium punch.
Medium punch is the answer.
Just...
You know.
Do your medium punch pressure like we've drilled.
Don't worry about anything else.
That's...
Okay.
It's okay if you use a DP.
What the heck?
Whoop.
There you go.
Get in there.
Good pressure.
Yeah.
Nice.
Lock him down.
Nice throw.
Nice.
Careful with the DPs.
There you go.
Nice.
Nice block.
Yeah.
Oh.
You almost had this.
Such a sick combo.
There you go.
Nice combo.
Oh, yeah.
That's what I'm talking about there.
Remember.
He's just mashing.
Just do medium punch.
That's your default.
Oh.
Nice.
Nice combo.
Oh.
You're in the combo.
So just...
Don't get too close to him.
Just don't get yourself in the corner.
Yeah.
And don't press big buttons.
Just play defense a little bit.
Okay.
Yeah.
Nice block.
Jump away.
Get to mid screen.
Yeah.
You're good.
Now you're good.
Nice.
Good defense.
Oh.
That's a good jump.
Nice.
That's crazy.
It's all right.
Oh.
He's nervous.
Yeah.
Nice move.
Nice throw.
Nice.
There you go SK.
Oh.
Nice prediction.
Okay.
That's fine.
We take those.
I can't watch this.
I can't believe you're doing optimal jury stuff.
That's sick.
Yeah.
You're capitalizing.
You're optimal.
Holy shit.
All right.
Nice.
Here we go.
One more.
Oh.
That block.
Nice.
Crazy block.
You're doing jury stuff.
I love it.
Oh.
Missed input.
It's fine.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter.
You got my ropes.
Oh.
That's insane.
You're better at the game.
Get him.
One more.
That's fine.
Eating a DP.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Just keep playing your game.
Yes.
Holy.
You're out.
Oh.
You're locked in.
Yes.
You're so different.
He's scared.
Wait.
Can't do anything.
Nice break.
Take it easy.
No.
I love the control.
Woo.
Okay.
You tried to do some crazy stuff.
Just chill.
Keep the corner.
Yep.
That's your corner.
Oh.
That's still your corner.
Oh my God.
You're a psych raid.
Oh.
That's fine.
Just chill.
Oh.
Do it.
Please tell me you got him.
Yes.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Yes.
Let's go.
You're so good.
You just proved it.
That practice was worth it.
That was ridiculous.
That was the plan you executed.
The training paid off.
That's all you gotta do.
The training did pay off.
Let's go.
Oh my God.
Okay, bravo.
Redeem me.
Hell yes.
Redeem my games.
You got this amigo.
I believe.
I believe in you.
I would try.
You got this.
I'll play my best.
I believe.
We've been in worse situations before, I promise.
No, SK has me hyped.
That was some crazy jury gameplay.
That cash-out combo.
Yeah, man.
I was not... Nah, dude.
You freaking did that perfectly, dude.
Oh, man.
Let's go.
Absolutely amazing.
That was sick.
You played your game.
That's the thing.
See?
Yes.
You've been doing that.
You've been looping that same offensive sequence.
Just do it.
These players are not blocking.
They can't handle the pressure.
You got it.
Yeah.
Hell yes.
Shaking, man.
Where is he, man?
Where is he?
Where did he... He's getting, like, training.
Last-minute training.
Steamroll.
If you remember, this is S-Fan.
He plays a little weird.
He's a little jumpy.
But once you get in, just cage him.
Yeah.
Don't go to over-commit to grabs or whatever.
He's a jumpy motherfucker.
Did I get mentioned somewhere on the stage?
No.
They tagged S-Fan.
They're waiting for him to show up.
Is it Crawl Pro?
Crawl Pro!
That's an act of aggression.
I don't get it.
Can someone explain?
I don't even know what that means.
All I know is that you're living in his brain.
I think he's going to kick you until you're crawling.
Yeah, he's going to break your knees and then you're forced to crawl.
Crawl Pro, dude.
I don't... Okay.
I guess.
He, like, played against PDX and he renamed himself FeedDX.
Listen, all I know is that you're living in his brain rent-free.
Yeah.
Get him, dude.
Get him, brother.
Okay.
Let's not do that.
Yeah.
He's a jumper.
So, yeah.
There we go.
It's easy for you.
It's easy.
I believe.
That was almost...
That's a sick callout.
Nice job, MK.
Callout!
Let's go!
Oh, damn.
Oh, that was unlucky.
Resets!
Oh, that's so bad for me.
No worries.
We call that an American reset.
Brother, that move is not good.
Okay, you got this still.
Oh, okay.
You're tired.
You're EP.
Oh, you know he's gonna give it to you.
He knows I'm looking for him.
It don't matter.
That jackhammer is not good.
He's not doing anything.
Why isn't he doing it?
Yeah, do it!
Do it!
Spin your fireball!
He knows.
He doesn't want to get jackhammered again.
The last time it happened twice.
They were like, wait, when did you get level two again?
That happened last time.
There we go.
Oh!
Oh, that would have been sick, though.
Yeah.
Oh!
Oh, the second carry!
Yes!
That perfect parry.
I love keeping it tight.
Yes.
Nice.
And tires.
Good defense.
Yep.
Nice!
Nice.
Yeah, he can't be doing that against Gief.
I like that.
Nice grab.
Turn your chill.
That's okay.
All right.
Nice get up.
Yeah.
Nice!
Almost had it.
That's close.
He's still got more health than him.
Yeah.
You just need one hit.
Is that going to work?
Oh!
That's okay, man.
Just...
Yeah.
Okay.
Don't spend your resources.
Just chill.
You're good, brother.
Yeah.
No need to be fancy.
Nice.
Here I come.
Oh!
Yes!
Make him scared.
Play some mind games with him.
Oh!
He's like, you're level one.
I don't need to throw fire.
I can throw all the fireballs.
Nice!
Get home!
Oh!
Okay.
That's close.
Yeah.
We got new combos now.
Let's go.
Holy shit.
Oh, yeah.
It's critical.
Wow.
That comes from so far.
Nice!
Nice kill!
We'll take that trade.
Yeah.
Just tap it in.
A jab or something.
Jab is really good with Gief, too.
To close out matches.
Yeah.
Oh, my goodness.
Big combo.
Oh!
There we go.
Yes, sir.
Oh, he's scared.
He's scared.
Another combo.
I love it.
We'll take it.
We'll take those.
The game just ended.
Okay.
All right.
We'll take those pro.
Your offense is leveled up.
You're not like going in too close or keeping corner because these motherfuckers are jumping and mashing.
So that spot you held, just like let them have a little bit of range in the corner and then just punish them for trying to wiggle out.
That's so good.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Let's clean, dude.
Clean.
That looks good for everyone else, too.
Brawl pro.
We have no match for brawl pro.
Let's do this.
All right.
Play your game, man.
Let me lock in here.
Let's go.
Do your best, Cole.
We believe.
We believe, Cole.
Play your game.
Let's do it.
I love hearing Brian say these motherfuckers that he just said out of character or something.
I'm very nice one-on-one.
But to hype up my team, everyone else is fucking trash.
Just remember that.
Yup.
Let's go.
Dad cursing.
My bad.
Nice.
Oh.
Nice grab.
Yes, sir.
Oh, nice.
You got this.
His MR is lower than mine.
Choke him.
You got this.
Now he's...
That's all he's going to think about now.
He's like, oh, I hope he does that again.
Nice jump out.
Yes, sir.
You know the defense.
What a challenge.
Nice.
Nice grab.
Yes, sir.
One more.
Oh, that's not a grab.
Let's go, Cole.
Play your game.
That's not a grab.
Throw a loop to master player?
Let's do this.
Yeah.
That's embarrassing for him.
Live on stream.
On the Sage Jam Slam stream, too.
Look.
We all get throw a loops on that.
Okay.
I got throw a loop like 30 times on stream.
That's why it's funny.
Doki says that.
Is that just a master player?
They all get throw a loop.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter who you are.
Nice escape.
What a fucking sick escape there.
Yes, sir.
Oh, my God.
He's so locked in right now.
Nice and easy.
I love it.
Good, Oki.
Okay.
Sweet.
Good, Oki.
Cole.
One more.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
He's so locked in right now.
Cole actually learned how to use the super.
I learned how to use my super.
Yes.
That is what you practice all night.
Yesterday, I...
Let's go.
That was great.
After Cole won, he started twerking on stream.
I'm like, what?
They got me off guard.
Yeah.
We can't open a stream after this.
Oh, he's adapting.
That's okay.
Oh, he's not.
He's just capping.
No, he's not.
He's just dead.
What?
That's okay.
It's fine.
See your mid screen.
Let's go.
Yeah.
He did what we wanted him to do.
Yup.
Oh!
I've never seen that throw before.
Nice.
And his drive meter is low.
It's fine.
I don't like this Ken skin.
I don't like it either.
It's all good.
This doesn't look like him.
Oh, my God.
Oh, nice grab!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, the grab is insane.
It's all good.
It's not going to do too much.
If you hit him, you got level three.
Is that a kill?
That's close, that's close.
You know, play your game.
Just don't jump when you're near the corner.
If you're kind of like jumping into the corner, that's it.
Everything else is great.
You got this.
You're better.
Nice serve!
That's fine.
It's wasting all the bar.
Yeah, he was mashing.
There we go.
You're back in the game.
Oh, nice.
Nice defense.
Oh, another throw.
There we go, Ko.
That's a jelly, some burnout.
Nothing to worry about.
What?
It's okay.
Don't worry, you live this.
Yes, sir.
Hit him.
You got to do the heavy.
Okay, it's chill.
Probably got an OD fireball, so be careful.
Let's go, let's go.
That was so close.
I'll take it, I'll take it.
There we go.
That's the offense.
Nice.
Let's fucking go.
It's Ko.
There we go.
That's fine.
He's nervous now.
We're flowing, we're flowing.
That's our Latino diaphone.
Yep.
Be confident.
Let's go.
Nice.
One more.
Yes, sir.
Is that it?
That's it.
One more, one more.
That's okay.
Nice defense, man.
All right.
We're good.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
All right.
No coaches match.
Let's fucking go.
We move on.
If you guys are confident, you're going to fucking smoke them.
You're better than everyone in your team.
It's so clear as day.
We got the one match out of the way.
We're set.
Guys, I think like...
All right.
I think I realize I need to stop thinking.
I need you guys to help me not think.
Don't think.
If I think, I lose.
I need to not think.
Just play your game.
I need you guys to fill up the discussion.
Talk about random stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
If I start thinking, I start thinking too much and then I don't know how to play.
Damn.
Not that GG's Cosmo, I'm a big fan.
I know.
I love his videos.
Toxic.
I thought that was Doki's job.
Oh, don't worry, I'll say that too.
GG's doesn't matter if I lost.
The GG's that was me is the number one thing in the fighting game world.
You have to have the patience of a saint.
GG's that was me.
That is an everyday occurrence.
GG's that was sandbagging.
You've got to be kidding me.
Oh man.
GG's that was sandbagging.
Dear God.
Alright.
Good shit team.
That was awesome.
Everyone's playing super good.
I'm playing against Bison next.
Yes.
The only thing to worry about Doki is anti-airing and then partying.
Cool.
Jump triangle when she jumps and that's about it.
Okay.
You got this.
And down triangle as well, the lariat.
And you're good to go.
Do you need water?
I'll be right back.
Are we doing it instantly or are we waiting?
I don't know actually.
They kind of tend to move us pretty quick.
Well, he said that they'll all be on stream now though.
Oh yeah.
Okay, so the next matchup is auto one dare matchup.
I think.
I'll double check.
So we got who we knew we were going to fight.
Yeah, Aldo's going to fight Nephew's team.
So Brawl Pro, do you want to play some JP real quick?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah?
For sure.
Okay.
Alright, let's do that.
I don't know what her cheese is.
What she does specifically though.
She does fireball into portal.
Okay.
That is.
And then she does a bunch of zoning.
So...
That's about it.
I'm surprised Aldo won their matchup.
Because Dia was winning their overall matchups in the first few days.
Hey, did they stream that just now?
No, they didn't.
Auto matches were not streamed on the main stream.
Oh, okay.
It was...
So, who won so far?
What's the bracket looking like?
It's Aldo versus Nephew.
Oh, they did stream us.
Yeah, they streamed us.
But they didn't stream the other team.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Guys, chat.
I'm making a custom room.
I need practice.
Bison only.
If you're not Bison, I'm kicking you out.
Yeah, there you go.
Modern Bison.
If you play classic Bison, I'm plugging.
Damn, dude.
No, because I had a custom room where it was classic Bison.
And all they did was doing the slide attack on me.
And I was like, that doesn't exist in Modern Bison.
You're giving me bad habits.
Like, now I'm going to be blocking slides when she can't even do slides.
True.
Dude, I saw the...
Once that happens, the Stand Fierce, the Fireball, you're going to get sent full screen, right?
So, she's going to do...
She's going to do this.
And then Portal.
So, if you parry this Fireball, and you see me go for...
Like, hold it for a second.
The parry.
And you see that?
Yes.
And then...
You didn't get all the way in through it, but you got pretty close.
And you can even maybe threaten the overhead.
Headbutt?
Or Wheel Kick?
The Wheel Kick.
So, let's see if that works.
So, if I do this...
So, you didn't get it right away, but you get in range.
And then you can even, like, dry brush into, like, something faster.
But that's, like, the idea.
Like, they're doing a lot of that.
So, you can see when I do the snap.
Yeah, you got in.
So, whenever she gets you full screen, she's doing something like that.
So, like, she gets a spike knockdown, right?
She does this, and does this.
And the only thing to worry about is if they teleport.
But if the zoning is on top of you, you're playing a minigame with these spikes.
So, yeah.
When the Portal pops, you're kind of stuck.
Like, these spikes have a lot more blocks.
So, your gap is after the fireballs.
Okay.
After the fireballs.
Not after Pierce.
Yeah.
So, after fireball, if I try to steal a turn, like, you actually block your parry and I do this, that's your main time to gain ground.
Now, the other minigame is with your dry meter in general, right?
Because he tears up your dry meter if you're parrying that.
So, you do want to parry the fireballs, but if I hold the fireball, it doesn't attack you.
So, you just want to actually, like, attack, like, parry late.
Like, go for a perfect parry timing.
You see how I...
And every time you whip that parry, your dry meter is going down.
I see.
So, the fireball will hit you later than you think.
See how much... See how late the fireball hits?
Go, pop.
See?
Yeah.
So, don't get baited by this.
I see.
And then, yeah.
As you approach, empty jump in.
You know, like, use your empty jumps to gain ground.
Like, yeah, that's pretty good.
The only thing you gotta worry about is, like, if you do it really late, like, if you empty jump after this, that can happen.
But when you're up close, early jump MK.
Like, early as fuck.
So, Nephew was telling me that you can actually jump early, so they're crouching punch whiffs.
That's called... Yeah, that's...
And then you can, like...
But, Ed, also, this is the same idea.
If you empty jump, like, from this distance, like, right here, probably.
Yeah, like...
Yeah, do it.
Empty jump.
Like, that might still hit.
There.
But, like... See?
Yeah.
I'll do light.
And in the heat of a moment, I might be like...
You know, it's easy to catch off guard like that.
Exactly like that.
And then if you're a little bit closer, you're gonna do jump MK.
Because jump MK is your earliest.
See how early that hit?
Yeah.
So, say I whiffed this.
You're, like, here, and you jump MK.
I can't anti-air you.
If I whiff...
If I whiff Stand Fierce here, that's a punish.
And you gotta do short jab, and not always dry brush cancel.
This match, you gotta be really concerned about your dry meter.
So, after you land your jump MK, do short jab.
Or, sorry, Crushing Light Kick, Crushing Jab.
What's the combo if you don't DRC?
So, you can go into Lariat or OD Lariat.
At least, OD Lariat is two bars.
Okay.
So, it's short, jab, then OD Lariat.
And then hold forward during your Lariat.
So, you can try that, or that's two bars, so it's more meter efficiency.
Or, just don't do anything.
Like, you have a reset.
Do headbutt.
Like, you always dry brush cancel.
Just do short jab on hit as a combo, then headbutt them.
Or SBD.
Yeah.
Right away.
You know what I mean?
Like, just don't mindlessly burn yourself out when you get a hit.
That's all I'm saying.
You gotta be really meter efficient.
If you land a heavy SBD, I wouldn't even do the dry brush stand light kick pressure unless you have a ton of meter.
Like, dry brush crash MK after heavy SBD.
Or, like, dry brush up and, you know, stand heavy.
Just don't burn yourself out.
You need the meter in this matchup.
Yeah, because he can chip you from full screen.
Yes.
Like that.
Don't fall for this.
Just keep walking block when that happens.
If I give you a fake fireball, now you're at a threatening range.
I could not anti-air you there.
Don't dry brush cancel unless you have a ton of meter.
Headbutt instead.
If I block the short jab, you're in range to then do knee.
Okay.
I muted myself because I don't want to scream at...
I was like...
I was worried.
I was going to distract them.
You know what I'm saying?
After short jab...
I'm so nervous.
Okay, wait.
Let me...
I'll def in for now.
The thing is, I'm super worried because the moment I have to think, I play a lot worse.
I do better when I'm not thinking.
Like...
In a tournament, it doesn't matter if I'm practicing.
Practicing is easier.
To like...
To not think.
But when I'm like...
When I'm in a tournament setting, if I don't think, it's just...
It's easier for me.
I start overthinking about what I should be doing.
I do better with instinct and reaction than figuring strategy.
I think that's why...
Also, it threw me off because Gumi was playing so slow.
She...
The first two games I played against her, she played incredibly...
She played incredibly fast.
And now she played super slow.
So that also threw me off so hard.
I was not used to it.
Yeah, she was like...
She changed... She literally changed her playstyle.
And I didn't...
I didn't know what to do with that.
And then I started thinking too.
So...
I started thinking too because she changed her playstyle.
Because I was like, what the fuck do I do?
Slap, slap, slap.
Oh, unlucky.
Okay, she...
I also burned out too.
But that's alright.
I don't need my burn.
What?
Oh, I don't need it.
I just don't do well with...
I shouldn't say that because people will be like, oh, she doesn't do well in slow gameplay.
I do so well when it's slow too.
I shouldn't say that.
Because everybody will be like, oh, she doesn't do well when it's slow.
I just need to...
Um...
I can not think when I play.
Not thinking has been what's costing me when it comes to fighting games.
Oh.
I didn't expect him to jump.
Watch this though.
Oh shit, okay.
That would've been cool if it worked though.
You know that would've been so cool if that worked.
Guys, how did my first match go?
I totally won my first match, guys.
We didn't go to coach's match, so technically, technically I won.
Oh, he missed.
Thank you.
Oh, whoa.
I looked at chat.
Hey, hey, hey.
I looked at chat, Jas.
I looked at chat.
Give me back my HP.
It's not fair.
Does it hit?
Oh, it does.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, what?
I totally went backwards!
Wait, I don't think I hit that.
No!
He jumped backwards!
You're stream sniping.
You're stream sniping, guys.
This is not fair.
He's literally stream sniping.
Oh.
Oh, that hits me.
No!
How dare you.
How dare you stream snipe.
I mean, I got one match off a plat player.
I mean, that's pretty good.
Shaking my head.
Stream sniping?
Stream sniping in my fucking...
Oh, I need to remember to not do that anymore.
Or not anymore, but like if they know.
What?
Oh.
It's because of that little bomb.
I've never had that hit before, so I never got used to it.
Oh.
I'm lucky.
No!
You're not supposed to be jumping!
Sir!
I need to cover my game.
He's stream sniping.
Okay.
Oh, he definitely did not expect that, though.
Oh, shit!
Haha!
Doesn't matter.
He's cheating by winning.
That should be illegal.
Oh, we both...
I don't want to do that, though.
Oh!
I also like...
I don't like that everybody labbed me.
I don't like that.
I like being the underdog.
I like it when people think I'm not good.
I don't like that.
People think I'm good now.
Please, keep thinking I'm fat.
That's all I want.
Haha!
No, I want to be the underdog.
It's more fun.
Haha!
No!
I'm still baby!
I'm still baby, guys!
I swear to God!
Haha!
I don't know what I'm doing.
I still don't.
To be fair, I actually still don't know what I'm doing.
Haha!
Nice.
Alright.
I want to be a child forever!
That's why I'm a VTuber!
I want to set against him.
Alright, let's see.
JesusRice, okay!
Holy shit!
Master versus...
Okay, I'm going to watch this.
Master Bison versus Master Bison.
Let's see who's winning.
Round two.
Alright.
Haha!
What the fuck!
Oh!
Damn!
I watched that just to see him lose.
Hahaha!
Just to see him lose!
The Bison!
Holy shit!
What the fuck!
A perfect K!
Oh!
Holy shit!
When you're mastermatched, this is how your game looks like.
Oh, we're finally...
Oh, they're running Classic too.
Hahaha!
When you head to mastermatches, you have to play at that speed.
Maybe you guys didn't know that.
Okay, I just want to make sure that I didn't forget to join...
Haha!
Maybe I didn't forget to join a lobby or something.
Because that would be embarrassing.
Yeah, they actually play that fast.
The moment you hit that elo...
Holy shit!
The Bison mirror match.
This is the better Bison.
They're all 1500 MR.
So they're both, like, nearly the same.
They can be hilariously one-sided.
I mean, look at this.
Hahaha!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Bison won?
Oh my god, guys!
Bison won!
Hahaha!
Wait!
How long are they going?
No, I'm stopping.
We're fucking...
Hahaha!
They're just...
They're just fighting and fighting.
Um...
They're just fighting and fighting and fighting.
Is there room to win...
Matches to win too?
So we can all queue into one slot?
Okay.
How do I do that?
Matches to win...
Uh...
Oh, here you go.
There you go.
I did it.
Alright, glue savant.
Alright.
I thought that was funny.
Hahaha!
They're just fighting and fighting and fighting and fighting.
I can't believe it.
Bison always wins.
Fight forever!
They're gonna fight forever!
Hahaha!
They're gonna keep fighting until it's over.
I swear to god.
If you're not modding, I'm gonna plug.
Hahaha!
I swear to god.
I need you guys to be modding.
I cannot.
I was so tilted.
There were Bison sliding and I was like, The fuck is that move?
Hahaha!
Today I was playing and I was like, What the fuck is that move?
Why are you sliding?
I've never seen that move before.
Like, this should be legal.
Hahaha!
I'm lucky.
Oh.
Oops.
I'm not thinking anymore.
But like, negatively.
Hahaha!
Not like the good kind of not thinking.
Oh shit.
Oh.
He does this.
Okay.
What?
I'm not even...
Okay.
Oh.
He knows how to...
You've been stream sniping me!
Hahaha!
This is not fair.
You clearly...
You clearly know my move.
Hahaha!
Cover your screen.
What do I do?
He's doing anti-air.
That's not what's supposed to happen.
Hahaha!
Oh shit.
Okay.
Oh.
No.
I don't want to.
Oh.
No.
I don't want to.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh no!
I hate...
The rock, paper, scissors didn't go my way.
Us stream snipers.
I know, right?
How dare you stream snipe me.
That's fucking right.
Whoa.
Wait, what?
Oh.
No.
Yes.
That's fucking right.
Yeah!
Let's go.
Goddamn stream sniper.
I want to do headbutt more, but I always... I don't know when to use it sometimes.
Which is like...
That's like my biggest issue.
Like, do I do this?
Okay, I do.
Okay.
Nice.
No!
I was... I stopped because I knew he was going to do that.
Oh.
That's fucked up.
That's right.
Impossible.
Oh!
I was going to do a lariat.
I blame ping.
I blame because you're on Wi-Fi.
No!
He jumped!
Stream sniper!
He saw my input!
He had a second account that's just watching my inputs.
Okay,
I need to stop doing that.
Because, like, I don't know.
I don't know if, like, they're going to adapt to that.
But, like, I definitely need to stop that.
It's not fair.
You're not supposed to be adapting.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
It's my turn to drive impact.
How are you adapting?
This should be illegal.
That's fucking right.
Wait, what?
Yeah, this guy's not bad.
This guy's adapting so hard.
No, please.
No!
There we go.
Do I grab?
No!
I don't!
He does that thing!
No!
He did it again!
You're so fucking...
You're mean.
You're so fucking mean.
That's fucking mean.
That was the way.
Alright.
Oh, okay.
Let's fight a masters player.
Surely this will be okay.
Alright, I'm going to death end just in case.
Huntress might be an all sham no wow too.
And then Nephew might...
Yeah, they might make a comeback.
Huntress is really good.
Yeah.
Well, automatically he beat Nephew last time, so who knows what happens here.
Oh yeah, he did?
That's a huge upset though.
If he does it twice in a row, that'd be insane.
Like, that's really unexpected.
Well, Diophon also took out Nephew as well.
So far he's the only two that he's lost to.
They're the only two.
Holy shit, Ross.
He's doing really good.
That was a great DI from Roy.
He just needs one more round.
Lock in Ross.
Close it out here.
I'm scared if he doesn't close it out here.
Wait, we want Roy to win though.
Yeah, I don't know.
I think personally we do better against Team Automatic.
I just...
I want to watch a good match.
I want to see the rest of them play.
Let's go Roy!
Woo!
Oh, what a big...
Oh, he's nervous.
We're just gonna beat Shyme.
You're Classic Bison!
I'm plugging.
Oh, this is bad.
No, if we beat Shyme, we're done.
No, no, no.
Wait a minute.
Oh, so we're gonna...
Even if we lose, we're good.
Let me win your Classic.
If you use Slide, I swear to God.
If you use Slide, I swear to God, it's out.
You're out.
Uh oh.
If I see a fucking Slide...
No way, Zip.
That's it.
It's over.
Oh my gosh.
I can't focus.
Damn.
Okay, now we have...
Might have an issue.
That's crazy.
Alright, well...
Wait, who won?
Wow.
He actually did it.
Good stuff.
He saved his team.
Good job for him.
Damn.
Got him upset, yeah.
I haven't seen all Shyme, no WoW play.
Like, at all.
Is he... Can you do this?
Uh, yeah.
I mean, he played against me last time, and he beat me.
I beat... We're 1-1.
Moira lost?
This is his first loss.
That's crazy.
That's actually his first loss.
Both of them are probably the highest level MR.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
That's actually insane that he lost.
Yeah, I feel like Petrus is the strongest opponent at that tier.
Yeah.
Alright, nice.
I beat a master!
She definitely is a grinder.
Let's fucking go!
Get out.
I don't know if he was fucking with me, too.
I don't...
My loyal fans!
No, you were on Classic.
No.
I definitely preemptively I was not expecting him to actually win.
Let me pull this up.
Let me see Sage and Sam.
Yeah, they might run it back.
Team Nepia has a really good chance to turn this all the way around now.
Yeah.
Oh, this would be interesting, though.
This would be interesting.
Whoever wins this...
Oh!
My god!
I'm muted, by the way, so they can't hear me.
Is it dying for you guys, too?
It's back now.
It was dying a little bit.
You have to refresh, though.
I'm muted.
I'm just nervous.
Alright, let's do this.
Who do I play?
You know what?
Let's go.
You better be fucking modern.
You better be modern, I swear to god.
You better be modern.
Yeah, they, like, beat each other.
I swear to god.
If you use that one slide, I'm plugging.
The other modern... Oh, thank god.
Okay, I was gonna say, the other guy didn't use the slide, so...
The other guy didn't use the slide, so I didn't plug him.
But I did say, if I see you use that slide, it's over.
Her anti-air stuff is so good.
She's really good at converting those counter hits.
I feel like he's just... There's no way.
There's no way.
He's fucking with me.
He's giving me this win.
There's no way.
There's...
You're just making me feel good, and then you're gonna destroy me now.
There's no fucking way.
I refuse to believe you play like this.
Crazy anti-air conversion.
Like, crazy combo.
That was a crazy swift punish though.
There's no way.
There's no way you play like this.
Alshan's really grinding for this comeback, though.
Wow.
I'll be honest, I...
I'll face either of these...
Both of these players are really good.
I'm very much...
That's no modern.
That's true.
I won't be surprised.
Modern apparently is very different for Bison.
Your offensive flowchart, it just... It's so good.
It's overwhelming for everybody.
Yeah.
Like, you know once you get going, it's over.
He does not look like he's played a modern control before.
Oh, he's whiffing, and then neutral a lot.
He's dead if he has this.
Whiff punish and kill him.
Damn, she got real combos.
Oh shit.
Oh!
Oh, I don't... He is, because he lands that.
Can't tell if you guys are behind or ahead.
I know that combo.
That she just did.
Let's go.
Oh, I'm... Okay.
Yeah.
Ooh.
The real chunk right here.
Yup.
Punish?
Yeah.
Nice punish.
Driver reversal punishes.
Oh, and he knows the perfect parry punish on the legs.
Wait, does he get that?
Oh yeah, that's fucky right.
Look at that.
He's so weird.
DJ?
Like, his move.
Like that, right?
That jump in.
So weird.
The bazooka knee.
Yeah, he's mad annoying.
He just shimmies in and out of all your ranges.
Like, your typical defensive patterns for checking stuff just falls apart against him.
He'll do like a low hatchet kick or the overhead.
That's fucking right.
Oh, what?
That's not fucking right!
Yeah, that down knee is really annoying too.
That's not fucking right.
He's probably like one of the most gimmicky characters we have right now.
He's learning modern!
Guys, he's learning it!
Bison is also, right?
Or is he not?
Bison is more cheesy, I would say.
Guys, I can't believe it!
He's learning modern!
But DJ is a little bit like that.
But also like, you try to take your turn back on certain moves and he just sways out of the way and then kills you while he knee hops.
His movement is very not standard.
He's learning in real time!
He's not at any Gordo level.
But yeah.
Yeah, it used to be super whack.
Even though he's...
4?
He was so boring in 4, I hated that character.
Low tier, but just so boring to fight.
Wow.
What the hell?
I'm trying to do headbutt, but I feel like it's...
Oh, she dropped it.
Look at her confidence, like walk-up throw.
Like, she knows to use the walk speed and...
Ooh, the parry.
Yes!
Got it.
Oh, you're mad behind.
Oh, he jumped!
I tried to be fast!
Fancy!
I wanted to be fancy!
Oh, he's burnt though, man.
Oh, she dropped it!
I'm gonna watch.
Oh, okay, never mind.
We play.
Yeah, that's the way you do the fireball.
Is that...
That was great.
Oh my god.
She has the combo.
Who's winning?
Damn, she did it.
Okay.
Yeah, she called out the fireball at level 2.
Guys, who's winning right now?
I gotta be careful.
Nice.
Yeah, when she had level 2, she called out the fireball.
Huntress?
Oh, it's Huntress?
Oh, okay.
DJ, OD fireball.
Wait, isn't Roy in like...
Yeah, playing his own game versus him is not good because he throws that out and he just dies.
Wait, how come... Wait, I'm so confused.
Yeah, he can level 2 a fireball also.
How is... Yeah, but Roy is in...
We'll see if he has the rhythm.
He dropped the level 2 conversions.
Oh, it's 4...
It's 4 seed.
Okay.
So stupid.
I thought I was thinking Roy is in the...
Oh, wow.
I thought Roy was last one in Coach's match.
I keep thinking he's the anchor.
I keep thinking that.
I keep thinking he's the anchor because he's so good.
But clearly...
Not anymore.
Sorry, I didn't mean that as toxic, but you know what I mean.
Everybody always assumes...
He's like the favorite.
So, people are always surprised.
That was a crazy grab.
Yeah, because Justin was like you should be the anchor spot because of how good you are.
Sorry, that was not meant to be toxic.
It's actually the biggest upset.
Oh, God.
It's pretty common.
Oh, the cheeky overhead reset.
You're dead.
Oh, my God.
That was crazy.
That's an overhead.
Yeah, I'm muted because I'm practicing.
It's not fun.
I'm practicing.
That's why I'm muted.
Yeah, they're playing the game.
Oh, he's higher MMR.
Higher MMR.
That's our GOAT.
Huh?
You're higher MMR than them.
MMR don't mean nothing.
No, no, no.
It means everything.
It's free for you.
We're playing against Shines team.
Next.
That's unsafe.
Have you blocked lightning legs?
It depends on the version.
The heavy one is safe.
The other ones are punishable.
But the heavy one has a big gap.
The light one is unsafe, but sometimes it hits at a weird distance and it's awkward to punish.
Okay.
I just need to get over my nerves.
That's really it.
As long as I don't think, it will be fine.
But the moment I start thinking, it's GG.
The moment I start...
The moment...
She's grabbing a lot.
I just need to make sure.
Oh my gosh.
Jump more.
I need practice.
She jumps a lot.
Jump more.
If you're watching, jump more.
She burnt herself.
That's it.
Jump more!
Not now!
Jump at me!
That's right.
Do that.
Keep doing that.
That was a crazy upset.
I saw the match after a while.
That's good.
I definitely know you stream sniping.
How was the match when you rewatched it?
What did you notice?
He was cooking, but I didn't think you were actually going to jump.
Jump!
Keep jumping!
I need you to jump!
He had the guaranteed win.
He was like, oh my god, I'm actually beating him.
Keep jumping!
Thank you.
Yeah, he got it, but it was...
He's really good.
That's good.
You don't have to jump anymore.
He's actually really reaction heavy.
More than the average player.
Okay, now you don't have to jump anymore.
You don't have to jump anymore.
No way.
Yeah.
Thank you for jumping.
I appreciate it.
I appreciate the jump.
Drink.
Drink that drink.
Both almost burned, dude.
Nice.
Nice delay on the media.
Alright guys, that's enough practice.
I want to watch the last match.
Alright guys.
GG's.
How does he find it?
We're gonna watch the games.
No, anti-air again.
He's playing like I play.
Confirmed to the super nephew.
Oh, it's nephew versus auto.
Right here.
Yep, yep.
He threw it.
He had it.
He messed up.
Hey, nephew deranged.
Look at that jump.
Nice.
This is the last game and then it's us, right?
Yeah.
Should be, yeah.
Nice counter hit confirm.
Level one.
It's gonna be near burnout.
Meaty fireball is pretty much guaranteed here.
Is that burnout with level one?
Oh, he doesn't have fireball.
That's rough.
Okay, yeah, this is checkmate.
Textbook nephew game.
Yeah.
Taught him everything he knows.
He makes Jury look like top one.
It's crazy.
Nice punish.
Ooh, dropped it.
Rare drop.
Jury is really good.
I gotta chive in here.
You guys always act like this character sucks.
It drives me nuts too.
No, she's bottom one coach.
She won the biggest tournament in the world.
Is she meta or not meta?
I don't understand.
That's her Oshibuff.
That's not how it works.
That's the Oshibuff.
Wait, but then why did everybody play Edge and Evo this year?
They didn't.
It's just players and there's like 20 characters you can win with.
And Jury won Capcom Cup, the million dollar tournament.
She's the biggest, most winningest character of all time in Street Fighter history.
Oh!
That is good.
Jury is good.
They're good.
How come Jury wasn't in top eight?
But that doesn't matter.
That's one tournament.
I thought...
But people tell me Evo is the most important fighting game tournament.
Was that a lie?
Yes, but there's 200 people that go to Evo that could win it and one of them wins that day.
That's just how it is.
It's not like... you can't look at one tournament and think anything really.
Listen, coach.
But you're looking at one tournament for Jury and thinking something.
Well, I'm trying to...
Yeah, you're looking at one tournament for Capcom.
Exactly.
I can look at a tournament that Jamie won and say he's top tier.
Listen to this though.
When he won the million dollars, he retired because he knew.
He knew Jury was nerfed?
They buffed her.
Wait, they buffed her?
He won and they buffed her.
That's a perfect team nephew.
Oh yeah, and that's it.
Wow, they made the comeback.
Yep.
Damn.
That's just the difference, man.
Alright, well, if we beat Shine, we have to play really, really hard.
One round at a time.
Let's just focus on Shine's team, guys.
That does not matter.
Think about Shine now.
Yeah, because for us to play JP and then I have to make sure I don't think.
What?
I have to make sure I don't think.
Yeah.
I believe in you, Doki.
I believe.
Alright, well.
Alright, let's do this.
Let's do this.
Woah, woah, woah.
I'm waiting for my custom room.
Gonna be fun.
Don't think, just jam.
Alright?
I just need to not think.
Just jam.
Don't think, just jam.
I can't believe it.
People change their playstyle.
That should be illegal.
You stick with a plan and then you should never change.
Yeah, it's crazy at these different tiers.
Like, there's so many quick wins for people to quickly adapt and level up that it does change very quick.
But, I also think that you guys are just a cut above, to be quite honest.
So...
There's not too much they can do.
Yeah.
What if I just pull a Bison as well?
A Bison mirror match.
Pull out Bison?
Bison modern.
That would be really, really not thinking Doki.
She won't be ready.
A mirror match.
How can she be ready?
Right, I wonder how.
Yeah, if I just do the same thing she's doing then, like, I'll just mirror it fully.
Mm-hmm.
Doki, just don't think, just gif.
Don't think, okay.
I'll try my best.
Everyone in her chat starts spamming, don't think, just gif.
Yeah.
All she does is jump.
Yeah, but what if she just stops jumping?
Then you know how to play.
Then you party.
If she stops jumping, you party.
You know what to do when she starts jumping.
When she jumps, that's when I know I can party.
Her jumping makes me happy.
Well, that's good.
We got this, we got this.
You guys got this.
I'm waiting for the invite.
Yeah.
Yeah, they're taking their time.
Like, let's go.
Let's go.
Oh, it's cause it's gonna be streamed.
That's why.
That's why they're waiting for SageM to get ready.
And everything.
I hate being first match.
Doki, my chat right now.
You should look at it.
What is your chat?
BroadPro's chat is actually really funny.
I like them.
What is...
Oh my god.
That's your brain right now.
My loyal fans.
Look at them go, dude.
Oh, did they send me in?
I think they sent it out.
Dude, that's such a great combo.
How did they do that?
That's great.
Oh, yeah.
They're Twitch monsters.
Damn, man.
That's so good.
Chat, copy them.
Let's do it.
Yoink mine now.
Copy it, dude.
Yoink.
For freaky-ass Twitch chat.
Freaky-ass Twitch chat.
I swear to god if I have to heads or tails this, I swear to god.
Man, I'm gonna miss the heads or tails mind games, dude.
That's gonna be something I will miss.
I'm not gonna say anything until they're like heads or tails.
She does better on P2 LMAO.
You did go 5-0 last time.
No, I was swapping between P2 and P1.
I still hate P2.
We're all close matches.
P2, you rolled them.
You know.
Alright.
Good luck.
Let's go, Doki.
Oh, she...
Yeah, she doesn't...
Oh, okay.
I mean, that works.
Nice.
Oh, okay.
Don't lock in.
Oh, whoa.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
You're in there.
Let's go.
Get in there.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh,
okay.
Now I know for sure she's doing that.
So, like, does Genji still suck?
What's going on over there?
What?
Okay, no.
We don't have these conversations.
I think she was lying.
Now I'm confused.
Oh, lock that.
Now you're confusing...
I thought she was, like, Genji?
You put Genji in her mind?
Bro?
We don't talk about that, though.
Just have a casual Overwatch talk.
Go ahead.
Oh, the anti-airs.
Okay.
So, Hanzo, huh?
The anti-airs are cute.
Yeah, I hear they're brothers.
One has a sword, one has a bow.
No way.
Yeah.
Pretty crazy, actually.
They actually have a sister, too, now.
Do they have a sister now?
What?
Kiriko, I thought was, like, a friend.
Yeah.
I thought she was a sister.
No, because it's, like, a friend.
No, because, like, she's, like, from a different family.
You're an Overwatch streamer!
You think she actually cares about Overwatch story?
Wait, do you?
I don't think anybody cares about Overwatch story anymore.
You're like a fighting game player.
We don't care about Free Fighter lore, dude.
We just beat ass.
I care about Reyna lore.
Okay, that makes sense.
She's not part of the family?
No, she's never been, yeah.
What the fuck?
No, she's literally a different person.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
That's cool.
She's adapting.
And she stopped jumping.
Oh my god.
That was sick.
Is there anybody else that's, like, a family member in Overwatch?
Hanzo and Genji?
Well, other than that.
I mean, like, other than them.
That's the obvious one.
Oh, Brig and Torbjorn.
Oh yeah, Dottie.
Which one's Brig?
Brigitte, with the shield.
Oh, I think I left before she came out.
She ruined Overwatch.
That's what everyone says.
Really?
I thought it was the hamster.
I agree.
No, no.
Hamster sucks.
Oh, the hamster sucks.
Sucks.
Oh.
Just press square.
Okay.
Down square, down square.
Whoa.
Oh,
no.
Ah.
Yeah, you just gotta press square when they're like that.
Yeah.
When they're super low health, just jab.
Just hit their team, you know?
Just when you're crouching, press square.
Like you're doing the big moves when they're low health.
Just keep playing your game.
Keep talking about Overwatch and what the fuck is going on.
I don't even understand.
Nice, let's go.
Nice.
Good bait, good bait.
There we go.
Let's go, Dottie.
Yes.
Oh.
Yeah, we just gotta block after we get hit.
Good block.
Okay.
Good squares.
See the squares?
Yeah, you block and square and then you can play your game again.
One of the best down squares in the game, Dottie.
Just laying in on her.
Ah.
Sometimes she doesn't, so I'm like, I risk it sometimes.
Which is not a good risk.
Same thing.
Yeah, it's fine.
Oh, I think she hits that, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, she's gonna get the auto-combo, but she's burnt out, so...
What do I do here?
Block and square.
Oh, nice jump.
That's fine.
Yep, now you can use DI also.
What?
You can use DI.
No.
No, I lost my thing, too.
Oh, that was so close.
That's alright, Dottie.
Lock in.
Let's do this.
Go, Dottie.
There you go.
Nice.
Get those triangles.
Let's go.
Careful with the meter and you're good.
Don't think...
Nice jump.
Nice triangle.
Let's go.
Get some meter back.
Nice jump.
Perfect jump.
More Dottie.
Let's do this.
Go for it.
Okay.
Don't think.
Just Dottie.
Okay.
Oh, no.
That's cool.
Does this hit?
No.
Just block here.
Just block.
That's fine.
You're killing.
No.
She got it.
That was close.
Very close.
Yeah, when they're low on life, you don't have to do the big moves.
Yeah.
Well, you started doing it.
We stopped talking about Overwatch and that's what happened.
That's true.
You guys stopped talking about Overwatch.
I started thinking again.
She was in her happy place, you know.
All those payload missions.
Yeah.
They all prepped for me.
Let's go.
She just likes to anti her a lot.
So just be careful about the jumps and play your game.
Get those medium punches.
That was very close.
I was so close.
Good job.
I believe.
Me too, for once.
Yes.
Let's go.
Your adaptation last game was crazy.
That was ridiculous.
Let's go.
I'm pouty.
Wait,
what?
A problem has occurred.
I got that too.
But it's working still.
Nope.
This time for sure.
I'm still in the lobby though.
We're still in the lobby.
It hasn't started yet.
A problem has occurred.
I kicked you guys.
Victoria is back in there.
All right.
Go ahead and try again.
Don't forget to take a break.
If you need something.
Yeah.
If it doesn't go well, we'll just take a break.
It's not working?
You might have to remake the lobby.
Yeah, a problem has occurred.
Oh, is the lobby down?
Sometimes two players just can't connect for some reason.
Yeah.
Yeah, try leaving and then coming back.
Victoria is back in the lobby.
SK is too, but it may persist.
Oh, a save.
Did we?
Hmm.
A problem has occurred.
I think we have to remake the lobby.
Remake the lobby.
Yeah.
I think they're going to try remaking the lobby.
Yeah, that's what Claire said.
She said if it doesn't work, we'll just remake it.
Okay.
Let's do it.
You know what's funny about the coin flipping thing?
Because the coaches are like, that's not a thing because only we were the main ones that, you know, kind of call for it sometimes.
But the thing is, the other players will agree to it.
They won't just be like, yeah, you can have your side.
They also want their side.
So I guess it is a thing.
Oh, I got P1.
Yeah.
Let's go.
It's P1, yeah.
I'm good on both sides.
Yeah, but you took the side that you know she's invested in.
It's all about nerfing her.
Exactly.
Whatever you guys want to do.
I do not understand.
He's just in the back.
It's Tekken coach.
It's the Tekken in us.
Are you sending invites yet?
Or are you still making the room?
Brian, if this was a hypothetical car like a Volkswagen or something, how many times would you pull over the car in this whole event?
You know what?
You guys aren't too bad.
I'd give you disapproving looks in the rearview mirror, but that's about it.
Oh, sweet.
So no pullovers yet?
Let's go.
Maybe when you're talking about piss buff in the backseat, maybe then I'd pull over and force us to go to a rest stop.
But other than that, we're good.
But what about the one and dones?
Why the piss buff?
I mean, cause that's way worse.
Yeah, I think for my next game, you can't let me focus.
I'm thinking too much again.
The moment I start focusing, it's over.
You know, are you sure about that?
Cause I feel like you won when I was barking random commands before, and I tried to let you play this time, and then you keep waking up with level 2 super and new things that I've never seen you do before.
I think like I just can't have like no talk, like when people stop talking, that's when I get in my head.
Yeah, so normally I'm yelling at you what to do almost.
I'm saying block, block, block, block, square, square, square, square, and then you do that and yeah, but like this time, like you're waking up with stuff that is getting you killed when normally you just kind of chill.
Yeah, yeah.
And I think, so do you want me to bark commands?
I'll do that.
I do like, I like like not too much backseating cause like then I start thinking too much about what I'm doing.
Sure.
I like what, I don't know, I don't remember what we were doing like two days ago, but like that was like the optimal for me.
Okay.
Gotcha.
Whatever that was.
We'll find the flow.
Alright.
Are you in there, SK?
Uh, Victoria's gonna do a mission error.
Yeah, she needs to restart.
She might need to restart the game.
Yeah.
I think I'm stuck in this screen.
Oh, nevermind.
You could, you could try to restart too, SK.
I don't know.
Okay.
I restarted or, ah, fuck it.
Oh, if you already did, then you're good, but...
Nah, it was right before the, right before we joined the lobby the first time.
Yeah, CFN be doing this sometimes.
Just falls apart.
I'm gonna play some Path of Exile after this.
I can't wait.
Have you guys been stressed all week long?
Yeah.
Yes.
You guys have been putting in a lot of work, so you should feel proud either way.
You too, Coach.
You guys learned a lot in the past week.
Yeah.
Making videos that aren't watched, that can't be watched or anything.
Very true.
You know, documents that aren't read.
That video started getting a bunch of comments from, ah, from Doki's fans.
They found it.
It's unlisted.
They're like, Coach, if Doki won't watch it, we will.
I was like that.
Wdragoons, bro.
Alright.
Please make a public coach.
Go easy on me.
I like Reyna too.
Oh, did they send the invites out?
No.
Not yet.
It's the same invite.
I don't have it.
Yeah, I don't have it.
Maybe you guys should not start yet.
Hold on.
Maybe we should go with the second...
the third match?
See?
That's not working.
If you have an invite from Klair, join that, but...
I don't have any invite.
These two are trying to start right away.
And it keeps failing.
But no one else is in the lobby, so we should get everyone in the lobby also.
Interesting.
Hmm.
Is it Klair's Should we get somebody else making it?
I restarted my game but the error still kept going.
And SK, you restarted your game too?
Are you getting the error too, SK?
Or is it just her?
I should try the battle hub maybe.
I don't know.
Battle hub?
We're going...
We're running the next match.
Uh oh.
Okay.
We're running Brawl's match.
Well, we're going to skip for now.
Alright, skip I guess.
Alright, Brawl's match.
Well, let's get everyone in the lobby.
I don't know why no one's in the lobby.
I don't have an invite.
I don't either.
Got that on lock, huh?
That looks like Myspace, doesn't it?
I don't know if anyone's as old as me.
I've never been on Myspace or know what it looks like.
But I heard of it.
Wait, how old are you, Ko?
I haven't actually officially said on the internet how old I am.
I'll keep it ambiguous.
That's cool, man.
I got the...
I can tell you like...
I'm 61, yes.
Correct.
Someone said, so he's old.
Alright, it is Brawl Pro versus GP.
Are you in Brawl Pro?
Yes, I'm in.
Brawl Pro playing Wipeout.
Alright, man.
Gotta get through the obstacle course.
I gotta remember.
Don't be scared of Driver Shin.
Driver Shin is sweet, baby.
And threaten your jumps up close.
Oh, right.
We can't skip because...
Oh, wait.
So we're not doing the next match?
Oh.
No, I thought we were doing Brawl Pro's match.
No, SolidBone said we can't skip.
Yeah.
They're gonna have to walk you guys through making a lobby.
Oh, God.
Can't skip.
We got a problem solved.
So maybe they're just gonna watch one of your streams.
Possibly.
I don't know.
They better not watch my stream.
I'm running copyrighted music.
They're gonna get owned if they watch my stream.
I am too.
Yeah.
We just queue-sniped each other.
Nice.
Or the same rank.
Might take all day.
Have you ran into each other in ranks?
No, I haven't ran into anyone.
Okay.
That'd be crazy.
And then if this doesn't work, maybe Battle Hub.
Yeah.
Because me and Amor had the issue.
And it worked out.
Battle Hub.
I don't know why it's not working.
Yeah, let's settle it with points.
Why aren't we doing the third match though?
I don't know.
They want to go in order.
It's like if it goes 3-0 or like 1-3 or something like this.
Yeah, it influences.
Like the match could end early.
Yeah.
Okay, gotcha.
Yeah, I think they want us to just watch your streams.
Okay.
Oh, so it's just a private stream?
Yeah, just to try to make it happen.
You're sharing on Discord?
Yeah.
That way there's no lag.
Perfect.
I guess.
Oh, share on Discord?
That'd be great.
Yeah.
If I'm lagging though, I'm going to turn it off.
Sometimes the screen share makes me lag.
Oh, then make it like the lowest possible resolution.
Yeah, you're doing 1080p 60 FPS.
You can definitely lower the resolution to at least 720.
Yeah.
Just make it.
Give us PowerPoint.
So it doesn't affect you.
I mean, it's 720.
Yeah.
I don't think it makes a difference though.
It's usually just like it happens or it doesn't.
Okay.
Yeah.
If it happens, let's cut it out.
For sure.
Yeah.
We'll just pull up your Twitch channel.
Oh, you're in there.
Let's go.
Let's go, SK.
All right.
Let's do this.
Play your game.
You got this.
I believe.
Okay.
Play your game.
Slideshow time.
Oh my God.
The slideshow.
Nice parry.
Okay.
Nice.
Get in there.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice parry.
Oh, nice try.
Nice try.
No worries.
Time to throw.
After the grab, remember, she's plus.
She can move first.
Okay.
Yeah.
I was trying to throw break at that time.
You can take throws sometimes.
Yeah.
Just don't jump.
True.
Nice.
Let's go.
Yep.
That's fine.
You're back to neutral now.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Nice combo.
Let's go.
Okay.
Oops.
That's cool.
It's fine.
Oh, I think I'm dead.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's...
Do you want to back out?
Yeah.
Let's process.
Let's back out.
Yeah.
Let's chill for a second.
Okay.
Yeah.
Am I watching the stream?
Just don't jump.
No jumping.
Play your game on the ground.
Remember, your goal is to just get in there and press medium.
And then when they finally block throw.
That's all you're trying to do.
Yeah.
When you jump, they anti-air or you jump into the corner.
There's...
There's no reason to do that.
So you don't...
You don't need to jump at her at all.
Okay.
And then once your pressure ends, she's just going to match DI.
So you get medium, medium and she blocks, she's just going to match DI.
So just get your dry brush medium.
If she blocks it, you try to throw.
If not, it's cool.
Just chill.
And...
Okay.
Just counter.
More neutral.
But not in there.
I'm not using the dry brush medium.
You know what I mean?
Just don't jump.
Yeah.
Just...
The jumping is not going to work.
Everything else you're doing, your basic flowchart will work against her.
100%.
Okay.
She's just mashing on wake up.
And you'll get...
Good luck, SK.
Let's do this.
Let's go.
I'm not shaking at all for the first time.
Kill her eyes.
I'll take these.
That's right.
Ooh!
Get them!
Nice.
Let's go.
That was beautiful.
Huh?
Uh-uh.
Oh, I missed my timing.
Okay.
Cool.
Oh, thank you.
Yep.
You're out of the corner.
Careful with your drive.
It'll let your...
Yeah.
Just chill.
Nice.
You got it.
Just play safe.
You're in burnout.
Okay.
Nice.
Good recovery.
Okay.
Nice combo.
Yeah.
You just want to...
Cool.
I jumped.
That's okay.
That's all right.
It happens.
Chill.
Yeah.
She's just mashing on wake up.
You just want to...
No!
Don't even throw her.
Just driverish medium.
You just want to press medium.
Okay.
Play your game.
No
worries.
Yep.
All good.
Nice jumping.
Let's go.
Ooh!
Nice.
Nice hits.
Okay.
I'm jumping.
Nice.
You got the momentum.
She's also jumping.
That's good.
Yeah.
Nice.
Take her to that corner.
See?
Yeah.
It might be too late though.
Okay.
No.
You're good.
You're in there.
You're alive and you have level three.
This is...
Yes.
You're good.
You're alive.
Oh, I'm going to kill with one hit.
Yes.
Don't worry about it.
Just stay...
Stay in the game.
You're in the game.
You got this.
I believe.
No!
Good try.
Oh, nice try.
Nice try.
Good try.
You tried.
It's okay.
Damn.
You played really well.
The lobby took us out of the flow.
Not bad.
Playing modern...
Modern players are...
It's an anomaly, man.
I wonder if the lobby works now.
Yeah.
Let's see if the lobby works.
Dang.
Good try though.
Alrighty.
Well, here we go.
We're still in this.
Absolutely.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I believe.
We got 100%.
No worries.
We got this.
I believe in our last three.
Yes.
We got this, dude.
They're all mortal.
They can all bleed.
Yeah.
Alright.
You got this, BP.
Just don't hate me.
No, no.
Nah, man.
No pressure.
No, it won't be, man.
Even if it doesn't work out, we can still take it through losers.
I think you're going to smoke, first of all.
I actually think that.
Second of all, no pressure.
I feel no more pressure after that.
No pressure.
The super TF slot is brutal.
Yeah, I got the super slot.
The third one.
Super.
Super slot.
Super slot.ds Can they get the...
know what I'm talking about.
Are they sending invites out yet, right?
Oh, there they are.
They're going up now.
Oh, okay.
We sent one to me.
Let's see.
There we go.
All right.
It's reverse sweep, baby.
Okay.
I got it.
I believe.
Let me know when I can start.
They're still sending invites.
Yeah.
Because is waiting.
I think everyone's all mixed up.
Yeah.
People are slowly coming in.
I believe... in the reverse sweep.
SK, you stop shaking.
I'm still shaking.
But it's cool.
You just got to remember that they're scared shitless of Keef running at them.
Oh yeah.
You have the scary character.
Even when they're trying to fight you off, they're terrified of you approaching.
So just remember they're scared of you.
That's right.
Alright, y'all can game.
They're all here.
Let's do it.
I'm ready.
Let's go!
I believe, raw pro.
I believe, I believe.
Alright.
I believe.
Hands up.
Let's do this.
Look at that smile.
Super speed.
Here we go.
Make sure to quick rise if you get knocked down.
Don't press buttons when you get knocked down.
Nice.
Good defense.
Okay, control.
You got this.
Fuck.
That's fine.
You got the corner.
Nice.
Exactly.
There you go, Larry.
They just want to jump out over and over.
Okay, that was fun.
Nice!
So smart.
Let's go.
Exactly.
Yes, good control.
Just keep them in that corner.
That's fine.
No worries.
Nice.
Dry brush in there.
It's okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
No worries.
But you got the game plan.
You got the rhythm.
You're feeling it out.
If they put the mid oil, don't dry brush.
But other than that, you're good.
You're going to get in the flow.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's okay.
Just block.
Yeah.
You're good.
Okay.
Yep.
That's fine.
It's alright.
See, they're going to start teleporting.
So just chill in the parry.
Okay.
Just parry.
Yeah, you have to parry the fireballs, but you're good.
Nice.
Alright, you're in there.
There we go.
Control that corner.
Alright, there we go.
Let's go.
They're scared now.
They messed up.
Just control.
They're going to try and jump out.
Just get the guarantee on you.
Yes!
Yes sir!
Get him!
Oh my god.
That's cool.
Combo draw.
That's alright dude.
That's fine.
That's cool.
Do you want to take a breather?
Take a breather.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
Okay, just make sure to not press buttons when you're knocked down and you got this.
Yeah.
Nice block.
Okay.
Oh yeah, you're doing good.
Nice.
Bro, I hate this character.
Yeah, this character is obnoxious.
Drive rush.
After this pierce, they're going to throw fireballs.
Yep, there it is.
Okay, that's fine.
I feel like I've just seen like two moves.
Yeah.
Just make sure to just try the drive rush.
Don't always parry, but when you do parry, look for the portal and just drive rush.
Get in there amigo.
Yes.
Don't be...
Wait for this.
Parry it out.
Yes.
Nice.
There you go.
Get in there dude.
You're playing too slow.
Scrap it up.
Let's go.
Let's go!
Get in there amigo.
Yep.
Okay.
That's the game.
There you go.
There we go.
Easy.
It's the round.
Yeah, just don't be scared to go in.
Nice!
They're so scared now.
Alright.
That's cool.
Cool.
Whatever.
That was a tickle.
Yes.
Nice.
They just always want to jump out.
Let's go!
Party time!
Party time baby!
Let's go!
See, all they want to do is jump out.
You got this.
You know.
You know what to do now.
You know what to do.
Let's go.
It's alright.
Get in there.
Just chill.
Just chill for a second.
When they have double portal, just chill.
But you're good.
Now you can drive rush in.
Is that overhead?
Yes.
You need to parry the fireballs.
Good.
You're in there.
Nice!
They're going to want to jump.
Just remember that.
Yep.
Yes sir!
Control the corner.
Oh no way.
It's cool.
Control the corner.
Yep.
Yes sir!
Parry.
Hold parry.
That's alright.
Yes!
Oh nice hit!
Hold that corner.
Hold parry.
Sorry.
Alright.
Okay.
I see.
You're seeing it.
Wait a second and then hold parry.
Other than that you're doing great.
Nice!
Uh huh.
That was your time to drive rush.
After the fireball you can drive rush.
Wait this out.
There.
Get in there.
There it is.
Okay.
Just chill.
That was good.
Good.
Nice.
Nice parry.
Okay.
Cool.
I believe.
Let's go bro.
Bro.
Oh I'm going to get shipped out.
Get in there Migos.
You're good.
Just jump out.
Aw.
Nice try.
That was pretty nice.
GG.
Sorry.
Yeah.
It's tough.
Did your best.
That's alright.
It's okay.
You tried.
That was...
God this character is so lame.
I watched that and I'm like I'm mad at this character.
Yeah.
No.
I'm upset at that character.
That character doesn't look fun to play at all.
No dude.
Alright.
GG.
Do we go straight into our next match?
Or is there a buffer?
Who do we play?
We play against...
Diaphone.
They're probably going to play on stream.
So we probably got a long break.
Oh actually no.
We might not.
We're going straight away.
Okay.
So we're doing losers.
So if we win this we're going to Twitchcon.
We're done for the day.
Do they...
I guess so right?
They're only doing losers round one.
Okay.
So who are these players against?
Amore, PDX, BoxBox, Diaphone.
Okay.
We know these players.
Is Amore actually playing Honda now?
Or is that just...
I don't know.
Can we pull up her stream and see?
I doubt it.
I think she played Honda versus Atlink.
Interesting.
Is it the same lobby?
Or is it a different lobby?
They will tell us.
Let's see.
Time to beat Saekuno again Doki.
You know what to do.
You gave him emotional damage.
And he'll permanently stay there.
I think he's playing Cammy.
I think.
Because Punk gave him Cammy.
Geek counters with Cammy.
That don't matter.
I think we have to wait for that.
They're going to run the other team first.
Are they going to run winners finals first?
They're running winners finals?
It looks like they're doing automatic JV right now.
Okay.
So we got a break.
Alright guys.
It's time to practice classic Cammy.
Do you know how to not back roll?
I definitely...
Okay, we're back at it again.
Not...
Look up...
Not Doki...
Uh...
For...
The...
Custom room.
I think it's also the vibes.
The vibes is like much more stressful.
Only playing against...
Um...
Cammy.
Classic Cammy.
It's like the vibes too.
And...
Uh...
It's like...
Yeah, the vibes are way too serious.
I don't fuck with these vibes.
It's like...
It's like a combination of everything.
Cause like now a lot of people are depending on me to win.
And like in the past...
You know, it's just whatever.
What happens to me doesn't matter.
Like...
Yeah, it's just way...
Everybody's like super quiet.
And every...
And then like I'm not worried about saying stuff.
Because like everybody is so serious and focused.
So then it's fucking with me too.
Uh...
So like...
It's like...
It's like fucking with me.
Like the vibes in general.
Like everybody is so...
Like I understand why.
But like...
It's like affecting how I play.
So...
Cause like my vibes are like...
Oh I need to be serious now.
Like...
Oh I need to be serious.
Um...
Cause I'm trying to be vibey too.
But then like...
No one's talking.
It's only...
It's only me and Ko trying to talk.
And I'm like...
I don't know what to do.
And like I get so nervous too.
I get really nervous.
And I can't...
Uh...
It's so hard for me to...
Lock in.
Cause I play better when I'm like...
Super casual.
So like...
When it's not casual...
It just... It fucks with me so much.
Yeah.
We need Kony.
Can I call Kony?
I'd be like...
Kony I need a vibe check right now.
I need a vibe check.
I can't.
I'm definitely learning a lot.
I think like...
Cause like my enjoyment...
Of these tournaments heavily depends...
On the vibes of the team.
Like when things get too serious I just...
I also crumble.
Because it's like...
Cause it's like...
Oh no.
I crumble...
Really hard when things get like...
Super serious.
Yeah.
I didn't practice against Cammy at all today.
I got like so in my head too.
Like I was...
I don't wanna say I crumbled.
I was like over thinking a lot.
When I'm...
I need to mentally reset myself too.
Cause like...
I start over thinking about how to play.
Because...
Uh...
Because I'm like...
Oh okay are they gonna do that now?
Because I did that last game?
Or are they gonna...
Uh...
And then it's like...
No I slept a lot.
I've been sleeping way too much.
I've been sleeping way too much too.
I even get like coffee.
But I'm still so...
Like not tired but like...
Uh...
Okay.
Let me make sure I'm doing what I usually do.
Yeah I'm hesitating a lot too.
Because I'm like...
Oh are they gonna do that?
Did they lab that?
Like oh if I do this it used to work before.
But like I'm also like really nervous.
Because I know a lot of people...
Labbed me too.
So it's like...
I'm like oh no.
Like are they gonna...
Doing this instead?
Because they know that I wanna do this.
So it's like...
Ow my head is like so full.
I don't know if Kony...
I don't know if Kony is online.
I'll call Kony.
Yeah I just need team vibes.
Honestly.
I hope like the next matchup the team vibes would be...
Better.
Because everybody...
Everybody is so serious.
And I'm like...
I'm nervous.
I'm so nervous.
Oh.
Oh no.
Is he still on vacation?
I don't know.
Nice.
Yeah.
Yeah I do better when everybody fucks around more.
Because like...
When we were spectating the last two games...
I like...
I don't know.
Everybody was so quiet.
I don't...
I'm like worried too of talking.
Because nobody is talking.
So I...
I get nervous.
Yeah.
Even though I was like...
Guys no more Overwatch talk.
I think the Overwatch talk was actually working.
I actually was winning with the Overwatch talk.
Don't think.
Okay.
Yeah it was.
I was like no.
No more Overwatch talk.
But then I realized.
Wait I was...
I was actually doing really good.
Oh no.
Okay I need to focus.
I think it's
also because like...
A lot of people...
Depend on me winning that first match.
So then I got so in my head.
I got so in my head.
I got so in my head there.
But I'm gonna...
I'm gonna mentally reset myself.
I'm gonna try and mentally reset myself.
Because I'm here to vibe.
Oh my god no.
And then when I fat fingered...
When I fat fingered the level 3...
I was so mad.
The fat finger of the level 3 messed me up too.
That actually messed my vibes up.
Because I was like...
How?
How did that happen?
How did I fat fingered...
My level 3?
I've never fat fingered...
The level 3 before.
I did warm up.
I played 3 hours.
I did 3 hours.
2 to 3 hours of Street Fighter...
Custom Runes before...
Before the...
Match.
Before the tournament.
But it was just the pressure.
Because I've always done better when...
Like during the Tekken...
During the Tekken...
I would...
Like we were just fucking around.
Like when I was playing...
It was just mostly me...
I had no intention of winning.
I was just doing whatever.
And we were just talking.
While I played.
But it was so quiet.
It was so quiet.
When I'm playing.
Yeah, it was just a hangout.
When it gets way too quiet...
I don't know what to do.
Because I like talking while playing.
And when...
I get so in my head when it's too quiet.
And so I make so many mistakes.
Because of it.
Okay.
I need to know...
I need to do a drive wake up here.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Nice, okay.
I need to get...
I need to reset my mental.
I'm going to see if Kony...
I'm going to see if Kony is online.
Kony.
Kony, are you...
Are you online right now?
Oops, sorry.
Sorry, I'll do one more game with you.
I was messaging Kony.
I don't think he is though.
Or Matman.
I'm just going to get Matman in here.
Are you online right now?
I need to reset.
Show me everything you have.
Round one.
Okay.
I'm coming.
Get...
Alright.
Oh, Matman is online.
Okay.
Get...
Take...
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Pause, pause, pause, pause.
If you're watching this stream, pause.
Go to the other corner.
If you're watching, go to the other corner.
Okay, thank you.
Hello?
Okay, I need you to hype me up.
I'm like...
I need some vibes.
Matt, I need some vibes.
I need you to hype me up right now.
Alright.
I'm going to hype you up, but in a non-hype way.
Because that's just the way it is.
Wait, why?
You're going to fucking dominate.
Okay?
You're going to go crazy.
You're going to hit the grab button.
And then you're going to hit the armor button.
And then, when they don't expect it...
Yeah?
You're going to hit the grab.
The grab button?
Okay, okay.
No, it got too serious, Matt.
It got too serious.
And I...
I'm choking.
I'm crumbling.
It's fine.
I know.
I hear the call.
It's like, damn.
It's so tense, right?
It's so fucking tense.
And I'm like, I don't know what to do.
It's fine.
You know, it's just video games.
It's okay.
It's just...
I mean, I was watching Brawl Pro streaming.
I got it on the background while I'm editing.
Everyone's like, oh, damn.
It's so nerve-wracking.
And I'm like, guys, I don't want to fuck with that.
I...
I know, I know.
Tekken's like a lot like, oh, yeah.
Like, do the funny move, you know?
Yeah, I was like, nobody's talking.
And I'm like, I'm so tense.
No, don't worry.
I mean, who doesn't want to win?
But like, yeah, it's for fun anyway.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, thanks.
I needed that vibe reset.
Okay, you're good.
Just remember, video games.
Good luck.
I'll watch.
Video games.
Thank you.
Bye, Matt.
Okay, we got the Matt reset.
We got the...
Matt reset.
All right.
We got the Matt reset.
We should be okay now.
All right, I'm joining back into the team call.
All right.
Yeah.
What combo are you trying to do, SK?
I'm just...
This one.
Okay.
Remember, it's that one you can do stand medium to heavy.
Because it's a punish counter.
Yes.
That will work.
And look at your timing.
It's so good.
So the worst thing is to just get beat up over and over, right?
So like, just...
Yeah.
If you don't get the perfect parry, you might not get much.
But just don't let this turn into multiple hits.
If she lands a headbutt, just chill.
If you get hit by it, don't worry about it.
She might just do it again.
See how you're getting hit again?
Yeah.
That...
We just gotta avoid the meltdown.
If you get hit by something, you get up and you block her parry.
Okay.
And that's about it.
Right?
Yeah.
I just ruined a Ryu's 9 win streak and I won and done him.
Nice.
That's what I need.
Just for you.
Nice.
Thank you.
I think also like...
I don't do well when the vibes get super tense too.
I think that's also it.
I was like talking to my chat about it.
Cause I get so nervous and...
Now that we lost, I'm kind of...
I'm like...
Alright.
Attention's out the window.
I don't give a shit anymore.
I'm just gonna chill.
I'm just gonna have a good time.
If you guys just play your game, I'm telling you.
Yeah, yeah.
We're just gonna play our game.
The only thing that's wrong is nerves right now.
That's it.
Yeah, exactly.
Just don't let the nerves get to you.
Just have a good time.
I'm vibing now.
Yeah, yeah.
That might be due to one of my magic dummies, but that's okay.
Oh, wait.
What?
You didn't hear anything.
Wait a minute.
There's nothing.
Have you been...
During the other matches?
What?
Well, you know...
The first one, no.
I couldn't even get to the second one cause you guys lost.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sheesh.
I don't even know how I'm gonna perform.
I'd live for this Akuma game.
You'd live for the Akuma game.
And I'm like, alright, I guess I'm just leaving.
So I say, if you block this, do you stand medium to crash medium kick?
Do you stand medium to crash medium kick?
I gotta face against Mbox.
Wait, did you do okay against M?
Stand medium punch like you're doing to crash medium kick.
Boxbox, we're 1-1 right now.
But I went and dunned him in rank on accident, but I still did it.
Technically speaking, we're 2-1.
Yeah, technically you.
Technically speaking, you lose the bracket.
Yeah.
But it's okay.
I mean, it's fine.
I'm not that worried about Boxbox.
And then you dash into it.
Let's go to the practice room, SK.
I am worried that he has my portrait on like a board or something though.
Cause he said, I will remember this.
He remembers this?
I'm a little worried.
And I never know when that guy is serious.
That's what worries me.
That's true actually.
Cause he...
I played against his Asuka in Tekken 8.
And he said, watch this.
It's gonna work 100% of the time.
And then it didn't work and I believed him.
And he did it and it didn't work.
He's like, oh, never mind.
I'm like, wait, I actually believed you.
That's crazy.
It's kinda a little different.
That's fine.
Who else is on that team?
Oh, Sykkuno.
Just give him emotional damage.
It's not that big of a deal.
Yeah, but he has...
Oh, shit.
No!
Sorry, I was playing against somebody.
I pressed the wrong button and died.
He's been...
He's been like...
Labbing?
Yeah.
Who cares, dude?
He had Pawn coach him.
Dude, come on, man.
You think he's gonna doubt...
Master's degree in one night?
No, it takes months to be able to write a thesis and...
I hope he plays Zangief.
I hope I won a mirror match Zangief.
Oh, gosh.
That would be so...
I don't even care if I lose.
I think that would be so fun to watch.
For my health, I hope not, to be honest with you.
But it's so fun.
It's so fun to play and watch.
I mean, that's fine, but I really like seeing, you know, you versus Cammy.
I think it's a really good matchup.
You should think about that more.
So good.
And SK really appreciates this.
I like that, too, to be honest.
Just letting you know.
Wait, what?
Wait, how do you adapt?
Stop adapting to me.
Yeah, adapting... I mean, like...
It's just gonna happen.
I don't know what you do.
The thing is, they can't adapt fast enough.
That's the thing.
You just gotta hit them so fast that they don't even know what's going on.
Look what hit them.
That's why when I'm like...
Oh, no.
Everybody is trying to actually play the matchup.
It's like, nah, dude.
Get in there.
Get in there, dude.
Who cares?
Like, on paper, they know what's going on.
It's like, they have all the answers, right?
But, dude, they have to still go to the...
They're not dealing...
Their brains, they're like...
They're not even SSDs, right?
They're just like Western Digital Blues.
So, like, the write speed is a little slow.
So they can't get the information fast enough to be able to deal with the thing.
If you can throw them fast enough.
You know what I mean?
Now, if they had, like, M.2s for brains, now we got a problem.
I don't think anyone would do it.
What the fuck?
What is this Cammy doing?
Oh, no!
That's what he's doing!
What's he doing?
He fucking baited me.
That's what happened.
I need to get some more water.
My mouth is dry.
I got dry mouth.
I don't hold down back sometimes.
I get blown up for it.
You need to larry it more, brother.
Yeah.
They jump at you, you spin around like a tornado.
Wait, who are you fighting?
Who are you fighting next?
I think B.
B?
BDX?
Yeah.
Okay.
You see them jumping.
Oh, it's another Cammy.
What the fuck?
Oh, I'm empty.
That's not good.
Is co-op an edible right now?
What?
I'm practicing all the Cammy's because I didn't lap Cammy at all.
I don't wanna lap him.
I run into a lot of those in ranked.
Yeah, but I don't play ranked.
Street Fighter ranked just makes me too mad.
To be fair, Street Fighter makes me mad in general.
But ranked just makes me more mad than usual.
Oh my god.
Yeah, and I was like, I won't fight Sykkuno.
And then I fight Sykkuno.
Now I have to actually practice Cammy now.
You know, other ranked games don't make me as mad as Street Fighter ranked.
I don't know what it is.
I'm not even happy when I win a Street Fighter ranked game.
Oh man.
I almost fell down the stairs.
That was crazy.
Oh, that is not good.
What if you have to play?
Yeah, what if you have to play?
Nah, it's okay.
I'm not scared.
I've been watching too much GEEF.
Wait, you're not playing against GEEF?
No, I've been watching too much of it.
So I'm like, I vicariously am GEEF.
That's what I'm trying to say.
No, we're good.
You guys wanna know a song that really gets me going?
Yeah.
Have you ever heard of Dig a Hole by Windrose?
What?
No.
Boot that shit up real quick.
And tell me that doesn't make you wanna dig a hole.
Off stream.
Not on stream.
Unless you have it split.
That's fine.
That gets me going, dude.
Is that the Minecraft one?
Minecraft?
I don't know.
There's a Minecraft version of...
Not Minecraft, but like...
There's a Minecraft song that has that...
Oh.
Dude, this song right here.
Gets my blood going.
Dig a hole?
Yeah, dude.
I got this weird...
I actually bought a tactical shovel because of this song.
A tactical shovel?
Yeah, so you unscrew the handle and it's like a knife.
And then the shovel actually comes undone too.
So it can be like a...
It's like a survival shovel.
You take it with you, you're supposed to survive with it.
What?
Yeah, dude.
It's so good.
It's got like seven different...
It's like a Swiss army, but a shovel.
Swiss army knife.
That's what I meant.
Oh no, I'm in the corner.
Don't do this to me.
Please.
What's a Yogscast?
That's where the song is from.
Oh, I heard this song.
I didn't hear this song from them.
This is a Minecraft song?
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
It's a Minecraft song.
That's almost like the Minecraft song.
Wait, is it this exact one, chat?
This makes you want to dig a hole, you said?
Yeah!
Yeah, it does.
It's the Minecraft song.
I am a dwarf and I'm digging a hole.
Yeah, that is the Minecraft song.
Yeah!
I didn't know it was a Minecraft song.
That's like... that one?
Still made of gold.
Common brothers sing with me!
I am a dwarf and I'm digging a hole.
I want to go dig one right now.
Wait, so you buy a shovel because of that?
Yeah, dude.
Unfortunately, my landlords were like, no, you cannot build dig a hole in our backyard.
But, you know...
There's no way you actually... that has to be...
I want to dig a hole so bad, but I can't.
There's no way.
My HOA won't let me.
Let's go to a public park and dig a hole.
I might go in the middle of nowhere, though.
Yeah, go to like a forest.
Chat, would you guys watch a shovel livestream, like an IRL stream of me digging a hole?
Honestly, people watch anything.
Inside my house?
I think that's illegal.
It is.
It's 100% not legal.
I think that's illegal.
I don't know if I'm gonna do that.
But, you know...
Whatever happens, happens, you know?
I've never played Shovel Knight, actually.
I should play that.
It's got a shovel.
It's fun.
I've never played Shovel Knight.
It's pretty fun.
Isn't it like, uh...
Have you played Hollow Knight?
No, I've never played Hollow Knight.
Hollow Knight is really long, too.
Is it?
Yeah.
Go to a cemetery?
No, go to the abandoned cemetery.
People clean abandoned cemeteries for content.
I'd do it.
I'd go to an abandoned cemetery.
I'll just make friends with the ghosts.
It's fine.
Actually, I don't know.
I'm pretty sure legally, you can't do anything.
But it's abandoned, so what are you gonna do?
Yeah, what are you gonna do, bro?
There's no way there's cameras or anything.
It's literally abandoned.
I'm just wondering, yeah, it's against the law, but what are you gonna do?
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Anyways, that's my little obsession with shovels and holes.
I mean, uh, digging holes.
Digging holes.
I don't have an obsession with holes.
Whoa,
that's not what I wanted.
Whoops.
God, this song is so metal.
I love it.
What are they streaming right now?
They're streaming the second other loser match.
They have the...
What's it called?
My seed going up right now.
The first seed happening.
So far, it's 2-1.
We play the winner of this, right?
Yeah.
No, no, no.
We're playing Dia's team.
And if we win with Dia, we go to TwitchCon.
Yeah.
So this is the last match we have to play.
Yeah, this is the last match.
Alright.
I mean, if we don't win, whatever.
It's cool.
It's fine.
I'll just play FFXIV, to be honest.
I'll go retire right now.
Nice.
I'll go.
I'll retire.
I'll boot up.
I'll log in.
Log in, boys.
Let's do this.
Oh, damn.
This is actually kind of close.
What in the world?
Wait, who's winning in...
Who's winning right now in that match?
So far, JB's team is winning.
So if Cosmonaut wins, they advance.
I hope JB team wins, just for the sake of the fact that during TwitchCon, you don't have to fight Roy.
Yeah, I just hope BroadPro to fight Roy.
You get to see that dude in person, dude.
You're like, a youth motherfucker.
I don't want BroadPro to fight Roy.
For the sake of his heart.
There's a lot of time.
There's a lot of time in between.
We're just there with like a towel toweling him off, you know, making sure he's okay.
I don't know.
For the sake of Broad... I'm worried about BroadPro.
It'll be fine.
Look, Roy lost today.
I feel like you're gonna have a heart attack fighting...
He did.
I thought you were gonna have a heart attack fighting Fumi, so I think you're...
Fighting Roy.
That was... dude, let me tell you, that was frustrating a lot, dude.
Well, yeah, I would...
If I was fighting that, JP, I'd break my monitor.
It's just, it's Gif in particular.
Gif has such a hard time getting in.
Yeah.
It's doable.
It's just different.
It's just, it doesn't seem fun.
There's a lot of time, though, to practice up.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I think, I've played Street Fighter, like, I think, off stream a little.
It's a little distracting to get to learn it on stream, you know?
Chat's very distracting sometimes.
Dude.
I feel so bad.
So, I hardly stream this game practice-wise, because I had other stuff to do off stream, but, like, I would...
I would tear my hair off.
Everybody was having a hard time streaming the game, because of the back-seaters, from what I've heard.
Really?
Yeah, like, everybody was, like, tweeting about it, too, and was like, I swear to God.
Oh, yeah, SK was like, this is the first time she streamed with the chat just turned off, like, the window wasn't even open.
Yeah.
For real?
Oh, I didn't even know.
Man, you guys suck, chat.
Jeez, Lou, man.
He was, like, saying, like, I'm never touching Street Fighter again after, or something.
What?
Yeah, because he was like, I hate... He said, if I don't, it's because of the chat.
Yeah.
I'm like, damn, brother.
It is a big question.
And I saw, like, I know, like, Amora got, like, really mad, too, when she was grinding.
Really?
Dude, I just started making fun of their mothers, or call out their fathers not being around.
I start, I start getting toxic.
But not against the game, but against them.
Like, I heard that, like, Nephew started, like, pulling up people's replays.
Like, anybody that starts backseating his students, he starts pulling people's replays up.
Oh, that's kind of godlike.
And then he starts, like, going over them.
Yeah.
Yeah, they're like, you're, you're, yeah, if you're gonna backseat my students, I'm gonna start backseating you.
No, that's godlike.
That's pretty great.
And I can't imagine Nephew doing it, like, enthusiastically.
He'll be like, yep, that's bad.
Yeah.
I heard a voice call last night.
It was so funny, dude.
I love that.
People don't realize, man, that streaming and playing the game is very different.
Yeah.
Like, it's just, guys, it's not vibey.
No, dude.
I don't fuck with those.
But I don't think, I don't know if I, I don't know if my chat has done that, but, like, I know my chat keeps saying spam circle more, but, like, I don't listen.
So, like, nah, just listen to the wind, bro.
The more you tell me the spam circle, the less I'll do.
Ah, perfect.
I love that.
I love that mentality, dude.
Your mentality's been really good towards all this stuff, Doki.
You give me such, like, I tweeted this out, you give me such 2011 vibes, it's freaking nuts.
Like, 2011 FGC vibes is nuts, dude.
It's just like, yeah, let me, uh...
Let me just one and done.
You did the ultimate sacrilege thing.
You ulted Fjord in the middle of a, after a round.
That was, that was crazy.
Or after a game, I bet.
The half and done.
Oh, yeah.
That got me so, that got me so happy.
Yeah, guess I'll go here.
Okay, I guess I'll fight on Master Cammy.
Let's fucking go.
Get him!
I don't know if I wanna, like, no matter what, we win or lose.
Automatic takes the first round.
If we win or lose, I don't know if I wanna stay and just watch everything.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know.
I'll watch.
I'm down to watch.
I'll probably watch.
I meant, like, streaming-wise.
I don't know.
Cause it's like... Yeah, you don't have to stream it.
Cause it's probably... Is it just one match left?
Or... Is it just one match left?
Or...
It's one match that left after us, right?
Yeah, it's one match.
Like, the Nephew vs.
Shine?
Yup.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, I guess we can watch Nephew vs.
Shine.
Yeah.
One more.
After this, Imma have me.
I'm gonna sleep after this.
I swear, the Street Fighter Sage on Snap has been the most stressful week for me.
It's been mad stressful.
Yesterday, I felt like I had a UFC fight the next day.
Like, I was like...
I couldn't eat.
True, me too.
I've been eating one meal a day because of the Street Fighter.
Damn!
You too?
Yeah.
I don't know why it's so stressful.
Yeah, we balding with this one.
Cause, like, the Tekken one was like...
The Tekken one is like...
I guess, like, there's less...
uh... risk.
Not risk, but, like, what's the word?
There's more management.
You have to think more about shit.
You have to think about your meter management.
You have to think about their meter management.
You have to think about their level threes and all that stuff.
No!
I've been practicing!
I haven't just been playing Yacht before.
I feel like Street Fighter, like, for some reason, a lot of people are so mad, too.
Wait, who's mad?
Does streaming...
No, like, when stuff happens, people get mad so easily, too.
On Street Fighter?
There's a lot of room for error in this game.
And...
I think that... I could say that pretty...
pretty nicely about, like, Tekken versus Street Fighter, is that Tekken, you can kind of mess up a few times.
Well, unless in high level.
But, like, in Street Fighter, in general, you mess up, it's like, oh god, that can be the round.
Yeah, like, I...
I've been so mad over Street Fighter in general, sometimes.
You just gotta think.
Apparently, Phi was screaming.
Yeah, yeah.
No, like, I've sent, like, BrawlPro, like, so many messages of being like, I fucking hate Street Fighter!
Like, screaming.
And then I stopped playing Rank and I stopped sending those messages.
After I stopped playing Rank, I stopped sending those messages, so now I'm okay.
One time I got a notification, I woke up, looked at it, it's just, like, AH, but you held down an H, and all caps.
And I'm just like, AH!
And then at the end, it's like, I hate Street Fighter!
I'm just like, well, good morning.
But, like, now, but ever since I stopped playing Rank, I stopped screaming into the void.
So, like, I'm less, I'm less mad, I'm just stressed now.
Yeah.
Instead of being mad, I'm just stressed.
I got to 1600 MR, I'm done.
Forever with Rank.
Yeah.
I was like, I'm gonna get to gold!
And I'm like, no, fuck.
Fuck this shit, I don't care.
Yeah, no, true.
True.
But, you know.
Yeah, BrawlPro is, like, the void for me.
The void.
He's the void.
He's what I use to scream.
It was funny, though.
I can't wait to uninstall.
I didn't say that!
I already leaked that part out, I apologize.
What did you leak?
The Doki saying, uh-huh.
And then, I can't wait to uninstall.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Alright, it seems like JB moves on, Team Automatic is out.
Team Auto's out?
Oh, so we fight JB.
You don't have to fight Roy!
You can sleep!
You can sleep, BrawlPro!
He's gone!
We don't know if we're gonna make it through, too, guys.
We don't know!
We can both be eliminated.
True.
True, true, true.
Very true.
Let's see.
That'll be funny, because, like, Roy lost to none in the Round Robins, and I only lost to Roy.
It'll be funny if we both fuck you.
That'd be so funny.
Yeah, that'd be funny.
That would be funny.
Oh, GG's to Team Automatic.
They did really good.
I feel like Team Auto was scary, too.
Super scary.
But I think, like, just everybody leveled up so much in general.
I definitely slacked on my training yesterday, because I just wanted to vibe.
I'll be honest with you.
It's like for fun, anyway.
Yeah, I'll be honest with you.
It's totally fine.
I also slacked off on training, because I didn't want to overdo it, one.
And two, I... I overdid it.
I did the opposite.
You overdid it, brother.
Like, we got three fairies in the morning?
Yeah, it burns you out.
Especially this game.
I could do that with Tekken.
Easy.
But not this game.
Like, for me, I just...
I just literally just did the training with Justin, and that was it.
And then I went to bed.
Like, I didn't... I was playing, like, fucking Roblox.
You know what's crazy?
You know what's...
You know what's insane?
Roy went 11-1, and the one L was to go to TwitchCon.
That's crazy.
That's insane.
Oh my god.
It matters, brother.
It matters.
That, like, just meant it for that.
That's insane.
I'd be fucked, but I hope he's okay.
Yeah, I hope so, too.
No, he's fine.
Because it's a team thing.
Like, Roy...
I mean, he did fine, right?
He won a lot for his team.
He did good.
Yeah.
So his team had to do it for him, too.
But it's okay.
Like, if it doesn't happen, it doesn't happen.
Exactly.
Ugh.
Is this 50,000 pot worth it?
No.
Is it worth it?
Don't keep your damn money, Capcom.
I don't want to play your game.
I'm just here to vibe.
Like, that's the reason why I signed up.
It's just, I didn't really care about winning.
I just wanted to vibe in general.
I'm gonna take... if we do end up getting to TwitchCon and we get to the pot, I'm just gonna spend it all in Vegas.
I don't even care.
And then you're gonna lose all the money and more.
Yes.
And then I'm gonna stop until...
I won't stop until I get to 50,000.
Come over here, Cammy.
Thank you.
Alright.
I just wanted to do that.
It's like KunoGeef.
Yeah, it happens.
I mean, you're gonna get... Is he actually playing Geef?
Wait, let me... I don't know.
Look at that.
Yeah.
He's in the room.
Oh, yeah.
You need to get in.
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
Let me... Get in there.
You got what you wish for.
Wait, is he actually...
Oh, my God.
We're gonna do a GEEF mirror match?
Do it.
Oh, my God.
Do it for the fans.
Okay, guys.
It's time.
Just grab each other all day.
He's actually... Oh, my... I've been practicing Cammy this entire time.
Are you...
Okay.
Get in there.
What did we miss?
Oh, it's like Kuno's playing Geef.
It's gonna be great.
Is it actually?
No, I think he's swapping now.
No, he's switching.
He was just memeing.
Ah, okay.
He wanted to... That doesn't work on Toki.
What?
She was excited for a second.
Yeah.
I was like, Oh, my God.
Really?
Bro.
Get back on... No.
Get back on Geef.
My arch nemesis regular diaphone.
No fuck.
No... Get your ass on Geef.
Get your ass on Geef.
No balls.
Why are you running?
Your stream title is a lie.
Oh, you won the coin flip.
Let's go.
Oh, did I?
I didn't even pay attention.
Let's go.
A true fighter will pick Geef.
I can't believe it.
I was so excited I can't believe it.
I was so excited for the mirror match.
Oh, well.
I was like, Yeah, let's fucking go.
That means I'm happy.
He ain't ready.
I wanted to do it on mirror match, though.
It would've been so funny.
Mirror match is...
Oh, yeah.
Brian wants to bark a little bit this time.
He said, just a little bit, but whatever.
A little bit of barking?
Alright, you guys get out of my Overwatch or whatever the fuck.
I'll bark.
Whatever she wants to do.
Oh, yeah.
He's so scared.
Look at him.
I don't think you see I'd say a damn thing.
What?
Oh, yeah.
He's so scared.
Just conserve your meter and you're good.
Dude.
Oh, look at that tickle, dude.
Is he neutral jumping a lot?
Yeah, just lay it, brother.
Yeah.
Get in there.
Yeah, let's not do that.
Let's not do that, Max.
We got the R1, right?
He's just gonna do jab, jab, jab into GI.
Yeah.
Okay.
So once he hits you, you're winning.
Once he hits you once, you block it out a little bit and you're good.
You got this.
Look at this neutral.
I'm impressed.
That's very smooth.
He's got combos?
Yeah, he's got combos, yeah.
He gave me the controller.
That's a move I hadn't seen before.
Yeah.
You are mine.
He's jumping on your wake up.
So just chill.
Yeah.
You got the feedback.
Russia.
Mother Russia.
Oh, he's Russian.
Yeah, he fought a bear.
Yeah, that's where the scars come from.
He's doing moves I've actually never seen before, so I'm like a bit confused.
Yeah, you just gotta block on wake up, Doki, because when he gets near you, he can jump.
He's doing this move.
I don't know what to do for that move, though.
You need to block.
Yeah, just block and then do DI.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yep, good blocks.
See?
Exactly.
He's walked a little and then he has to approach you.
There you go.
Go ham.
Let's go.
Get in there.
Let the demons out.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah.
Keep going.
Don't let up.
Okay, you're good.
Block a little.
Just block a little.
Cool.
Yeah.
Now, just conserve your meter.
Get in there.
This playstyle has been downloaded.
Okay.
Download complete, amigo!
Oh my gosh.
Download complete.
The main thing is just block a little if he hits you and then you get to play again.
That's it.
And then you win.
Where are you going?
I'm not going to jump anymore.
Just block a little.
Yeah!
Nice!
Oh!
You had a good idea though.
Yeah, I did.
I knew he was going to do that.
Just block.
You just got to block when he knocks you down.
That's it.
Okay.
Now he's going to try to throw.
You can jump.
Yeah!
Get him!
Nice putting!
Damage.
Level 3 on the table.
Yeah, if you get a DI...
For the loyal fans.
He's so scared of it.
He's very aware.
He's so scared, Doki.
You have no idea how scared he is.
Jump at him.
Yeah, what's he going to do?
He does this.
Yeah, get him!
Level 3!
One more.
One more and you got it.
I need one more.
Oh, do that.
Sit on him again, bro.
You can press squares.
Sit on him.
Nice.
Okay.
Let's go.
I think he likes it when you sit on him.
Yeah, the wheel kick.
I'm going to call it that.
What's that move?
No, that's that move.
The wheel kick?
Yeah.
Yeah, the wheel kick.
Get in there.
No good.
Just block and wake up.
Just block.
Nice.
Oh, I like that.
Lariat.
Yeah.
Good try.
Just block.
You're good.
Yeah, just block it out.
No problem.
Wow.
Gave you the controller again.
Nice anti-air.
Here we go, Doki.
You're in there.
Let the demons out.
Every one of his combos is just one of your grabs.
Yeah.
Drive rush at him.
Just do something.
Get in there.
Yeah, make something happen.
Yeah.
Okay, just block a little.
You're good.
He has to play your game.
Yes, now just walk towards him.
Jump at him.
Don't use that move.
That's the only move you don't want to use.
Yeah, that's it.
Don't do that.
Dribble the bar.
Nice.
Yeah, just chill on your meter.
And then just keep walking towards him.
And then jump with an axe or something.
Oh, I didn't realize I can't throw that.
Don't worry.
Just block.
Very good.
You're still in there.
You're so alive.
We're good, gamer.
No worries.
That's cool.
Just gotta block and wake up.
And you beat him.
Or grabs.
Yeah, go at him.
Don't overthink.
Drive rush in there.
Yeah, don't overthink.
Don't worry about it.
Just block after this.
You're mashing DI.
Just block.
No worries.
Okay.
Nice.
There you go.
Now you're out.
No worries.
I'm a believer.
I'm a believer too.
Yeah!
He does wake up.
He just guessed right there.
Whatever.
You're in there.
He's so scared.
His heart rate's racing.
I don't know what to do here though.
Oh my goodness.
My loyal fans.
Do it for the fans.
Nice jump.
Nice triangle.
That's perfect!
Let's go.
Nice comeback, Doki.
One more.
Let's get it.
One more and you're done for the day.
Oh, I keep forgetting I can't grab that when he does that.
Cool.
It's just the tickle.
This is just one grab.
Don't sweat it.
Oh my god, that angle.
They know what they're doing.
Nice.
Nice angle.
I didn't mean to do that.
That was a mistake.
That doesn't matter.
Okay.
Yeah, I get it sometimes too.
Nice.
No.
Nice try.
Don't sweat it.
That was close.
We'll handle this.
No worries, Doki.
We got this.
We'll avenge you.
We'll do our best.
Why do we have to lose, guys?
That was a good try, Doki.
We got nothing to lose.
I've never seen him even in my custom.
So I was so confused.
He was doing combos.
That's the thing.
If he hit you, he actually turned it into a lot of damage.
Yeah.
So he leveled up.
Dude, Amur is so toxic.
What is this?
What is this E Honda?
What is she doing?
What is going on with this Honda?
Oh, she picked Honda?
They're just memeing, dude.
There's no way.
That's not real.
Okay.
It doesn't matter.
I think the entire team is going to do this.
I'm calling it.
Let's see.
Okay, wait a minute.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, he's actually playing Honda?
Yeah, she's on Honda.
What the heck?
A matchmaking error occurred.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, no.
Not again.
Damn.
Might have to make that lobby thing again.
Again?
The DC again?
The matchmaking error will stay.
It won't go away.
Yeah, I think you have to do a private ask.
Oh, it's loading?
Oh, it's loading.
Oh, nice.
This is the first time this has happened.
It fixed itself.
It just randomly fixed itself.
Do your thing.
And remember, if we don't make it, Seijam is still giving us 60+.
It's okay.
We don't make it.
We're free.
That's like a new game.
Still giving us 60 bucks, bro.
I can't believe it.
And a controller, apparently.
Wait, we get a controller?
Holy shit.
Hell yeah.
I'm just a Seijam controller collector.
Oh, get in there, SK.
Nice.
Very good.
This is the game.
Yeah, keep walking forward.
Mm-hmm.
Dude, I'm more.
What are we doing?
Nice.
Get in there, get in there.
Oh my god.
Was she, like, playing this off stream all night?
Again.
Oh, good punish, too.
Uh-huh.
Time to go in.
You know how to play this.
That's cool.
Nice.
Uh-huh.
Oh.
That's okay.
That's cool.
Keep it cool.
Get in there.
That was a punish.
You know it.
You know the matchup.
Let's go.
Yep.
All right.
That was fake.
No worries.
Here's some beans.
Oh, nice.
Cool.
That's cool.
It's cool.
Rock it out.
What the fuck?
I think I know.
It's modern.
Oh, it's modern.
Yeah, they're just gonna try to get a random combo.
Go live if it's modern, yeah.
I believe in the comeback.
Very good.
It will be grand.
Get in there.
Oh, that's okay.
Oh, that was so close.
The comeback was insane, though.
You got this.
You're playing really good.
Yeah, confidence.
I like that.
Get in there.
Just block after you finish your moves.
Okay.
You're good.
Nice!
Yeah, let's go!
Oh my god, that was insane.
Those perfect parry trainings are starting to pay off.
Just block after...
Yeah, just block, remember.
She's just mashing.
Nice anti-air.
How come everybody jumps for you guys but no one jumps for me anymore?
Is that unfunishable?
It's negative.
You can move first.
Nice!
You have it.
You can kill next hit.
Ah!
Oh my god!
We take those!
Yeah, Espy, you're playing so good.
Just remember, after your turn's over, just block.
She's just mashing auto-combo and it goes into the big hands.
And then you can just jump away after you block the big hands or press medium.
So if you just block after your turn, she's gonna waste meter and it's all over.
So, that's it.
That's a win.
I just noticed all the people I fought stopped jumping and then you guys get all the jumpers.
It's not fair.
I literally had to...
You wanna switch seeds?
No, that's fine.
But it's just not fair.
Everybody literally stopped jumping today.
I did not do a single air SPD because of it.
Doskoi.
Headbutts.
Oh, you were going for the hard stuff.
Yeah, just dry brush in.
Okay.
Yeah, I say just dry brush in.
After she does a headbutt, she jumps away.
Just walk forward and try to gain ground.
Yeah, get in there, dude!
Yeah!
Oh, nice!
Almost.
Now we just block it out.
We're good.
We just blocked, remember?
We do a little mashing.
Yeah, it's fine.
Yeah!
We have a little perfect pairing!
And the optimal combo!
Woo!
There we go.
We're mashing too.
Okay.
Oh, burnt out.
Time to party.
Time to party now.
We started now.
Now.
Nice!
Level 3.
Ayyyy.
Nice try, nice try.
Yeah, she's doing heavy headbutt.
The one you can DI.
So if you want to do that when she does it fullscreen, that's okay too.
But just remember, just block after your turn.
And then dry brush in when you have a gap.
We do a little mashing here.
Okay.
Yeah, get in there!
Nice!
Holy...
It's okay, it's okay.
Nice.
That's fine.
She's gonna randomly headbutt.
Oh my god.
Sykkuno totally punk told him to stop.
Don't jump against me.
Let's see.
Stop jumping!
The world champion difference.
Yes.
Almost had it.
Just after he hits you, just keep blocking.
Just block.
Okay.
Yes, just block.
Those moves are very unsafe.
I hate blocking too.
Where's my movement?
Why can't I go into the z-axis?
Nice.
She's blocking a lot, you can throw her.
Yep,
this is the evil of modern Honda.
But we...
I mean, you have a Honda, but we have an SK, dude.
I need to stop doing that.
Just block, yeah.
Just block.
Yeah, just gotta block after your turn's over.
You're still alive.
You got this.
I hate this.
This neutral...
Aww, that's close.
Good try, SK.
But I know where it's brutal.
It's really hard to learn it on the fly.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
We can't expect that of anybody.
That was a good try, though.
I 100% understand.
Alright, BrawlPro.
You got this, dude.
Where are you fighting?
Oh, you're fighting Fi.
Okay, back to Tekken.
Back to Tekken.
I was gonna say, that's not BrawlPro.
Let's do this.
I knew I should've learned Modern Bison today.
For the ultra mixup.
Alright, Fi.
Let's have a good fight, man.
Let's have a good fight.
Yeah.
I'll just play my best.
Is he traumatized from fighting you in all the slams already?
He's fine.
Use that buff in your favor.
That's all I'm saying.
Yeah, okay.
Go.
Yes,
sir.
Headbutt.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, please.
Let's go.
That's a good first round.
Uh-huh.
Stay in the ground, amigo.
Oh.
Was that what I thought it was?
I got full screen.
It's fine.
Yeah, just don't press too much and you're good.
Nice.
Good job.
That's fine.
Yes.
Sit down.
Level 2.
Oh, he gave up his corner.
Yep.
Go.
Now you're playing Street Fighter.
You're good.
This is Street Fighter.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Just for all that damage?
That's all she did?
Yeah, dude.
She tickles you for a couple of...
She got to tickle you a couple of times to win.
Oh, no.
It's not fair.
He's jumping, too.
He's choking.
Don't worry.
Oh, yeah.
Yep, yep, yep.
What the fuck?
This Cammy can jump?
Where's my jumping Cammy?
Seeing everybody.
Oh.
Buddy, stop jumping.
It's so stupid.
All Tykudo did was jump.
I'm sorry.
He keeps saying that.
He jumped.
It's the truth.
Reality check.
They jumped every time.
Tykudo jumped every single time.
No, he didn't jump at me.
Yes, he did.
Over and over.
Get in there.
Not when it mattered.
That's true.
He didn't do it when it mattered.
I agree with you there.
True.
Oh, the low.
I have to hold down back.
That's a problem I have.
Oh, they're burnt out, though.
Oh, come on.
I hate when they end up on the other side.
And I try to anti it.
Yeah, it's fine.
No worries.
Okay, let's stop jumping.
I'm coming.
There we go.
Okay, get some meter back.
Yeah, nice play.
Damn it.
That's fine.
Just tickles.
Oh, nice.
They're in the corner.
Nice, Lariat.
Yes.
Hold down back.
Does that do anything?
He's fine.
Oh, never mind.
I'm looking at the wrong one.
Woo.
Nice.
Nice duck.
I was looking for level one.
Oh, that would have been sick.
Oh.
Oh, you do have level three on stuff.
I understand if you want to save it.
Save it for round three.
Ugh.
Fuck.
Good jump, good jump, good jump.
Okay.
You've got a lot of blows into drive rush, right?
Yeah.
So you've got to block your toes.
If he gets a throw, that's fine.
Okay.
You're just exposing the toes a lot.
Yeah.
But just don't be scared to rush him down either.
He gets so flustered when you rush him.
Here you go.
Nice sweep.
Yeah.
Nice poke him.
Nice.
Dammit.
I'm playing really bad.
There we go.
Composure.
You got this.
that was a little messed up, exactly.
Yes, sir.
Ooh.
Get that damage.
Wow, he did that.
That finally is cornered.
Yes!
Nice throw!
Take her to church!
Go!
God, driver's knee sucks.
Two?
Oh, he's buffering that DP.
My driver's knee is godlike.
Oh my gosh, the mind games here.
Oh yeah, me chillin'.
Yeah!
Nice.
The entire room is crazy.
Here we go.
Oh my god!
Nice hit!
Is he dead?
It's gonna be close.
No, I don't think he's dead.
Oh my god!
Classic!
Yo, brother, that was sick.
No, that's a Twitch clip.
Bro, bro, bro!
I gotta get his reaction for that one.
You gotta get his reaction?
That's fuuuck!
Holy shit.
My loyal fans!
Alright, time to go home, chat.
This is it.
You got this, co.
Remember it.
Time to go home, chat.
FFXIV awaits.
You know how to play against them.
You got this.
Alright.
We were in the lab.
Let's go, man.
If I do lose this, I'm sorry.
That's alright.
We're free.
You've been cooking?
You got this.
He's playing modern, so he does DP.
Whatever you had, did it hit?
What?
Co, just blame on that.
Whatever you had there.
What's hitting is his time in training mode and practicing diligently.
That's what's hitting right now.
Oh, you're the Latino diaphone?
Okay.
Yeah, I'm the Latino diaphone.
What happened to the other guy?
Which one?
I do a different player every day.
Oh.
Yeah, so I was the Hispanic broski, I was the Spanish Hikaru, and now I'm the Latino diaphone.
All of them are Aki players.
Someone in my chat was like, B is so sad.
When you lose to random drivers level 3 from Beef, it's okay to feel sad.
Yeah, I would feel sad too, to be honest.
That would destroy my moral.
You get a license to feel sad right there.
A license to feel sad, I like that.
Someone said he ran ads.
He ran ads?
At least monetize the toxic performance.
That's smart.
I should have ran ads too.
Yeah, true, true, true.
I would do that too.
Oh my gosh, I forgot to do that.
I never run ads.
I let YouTube do it for me.
I got this, dudes.
Dragon Ball Z, let's fucking go.
Yes, sir.
Huddle down.
Mm-hmm.
Look at this.
Good parries.
Ow.
Pocket sand.
Oh yeah, that's right.
He DI's a lot in the corner.
I forgot about that.
Yeah, he always goes for random DI, but you're alive, you're good.
Oh, you messed up, amigo.
Yes, sir.
Nice.
Then let him do the pocket sand.
Oh, not the pocket sand.
He's burnt?
Oh yeah.
What is he doing?
I'm not burnt out, amigo.
You are, dude.
Oh shit.
What?
Oh.
There we go.
I think he got confused.
I like the confidence.
I messed them up.
I messed the life bars up too all the time and the stun bars.
He forgot he was P2.
Uh-oh.
Ah, the neutral jumps, yes.
Yes, that's what he does.
You know him.
Uh-huh.
Nice.
That's my goat.
Uh-huh.
Uh-oh.
You're going to drive rush at me, dude.
Bruh.
Oh, you got hit by that?
The defense, that's good.
Oh, nice.
Oh, level three.
Yes.
I burned him out.
Smart play.
Let's go.
Very smart.
Hold on.
I still got to worry about his level three, though.
Yeah.
Modern three and you're good.
Nice fireball.
Oh, nice grab.
Oh.
He might be desperate.
All right.
We're good.
I'm desperate too.
Yeah.
Okay.
We take those.
Dude, I love whipping grab in front.
That's a classic.
That's a classic frame trap right there.
Yeah.
Keep doing it.
Let's go.
I got Barry the Light in my ear.
I don't think I can lose.
Oh, DMC time.
Yeah, dude.
Yeah.
Ouch.
Oh.
He's...
Stop with the pocket sand.
Uh-oh.
Nice break.
Oh.
Nice jabs.
Yes.
The pressure.
Oh.
Hmm.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
He's just...
Dragon punch.
Oh.
What?
That was actually a good move from him.
Modern.
Oh.
He's burnt.
Just be careful about his level one.
Oh.
I didn't realize.
You're burnt too.
I am.
I am burnt.
Unfortunately.
Nice.
Get those plus frames.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
What do you mean, uh-oh?
I should...
That's fine.
Oh.
Now it's uh-oh.
That's fine.
That was a good try.
Oh, wow.
Nice.
Good jump out.
Yeah.
Paid attacks.
Hmm.
He's adapting.
All right.
Good stuff.
That was good.
Box mod.
He's playing very fearless.
He just...
He's very...
Yeah.
Very safe.
In the corner, you got to look for DI.
That's about it.
Mid-screen, you know, you can try back dashing or something, get away from the throws, but...
Or just block it out.
But you're playing really good.
I'm going to try something here.
Is it that?
Yeah.
Just string him up.
Stop going for the throw.
Do the heavy kick on him.
This man is mashing.
So like...
Get in there.
When you get in there, press that heavy kick.
Yes, sir.
Nice.
Sir.
Burned out.
He has level one, though.
It's fine.
Maybe I'll save it.
Nice combo.
Oh, nice.
Very clean.
That was a sick-ass jump.
One more miss.
Oh, nice tech.
Nice tech.
He's burned out again.
Level two?
Oh, he dropped two.
No, he...
Yeah, he wore it.
Oh, nice tech.
Two shots.
Oh, that was it.
He was unlucky.
I'm just going to chip him out.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, you're welcome, coach.
That was for you.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
That was nerve-wracking there.
He's like, do I do something fancy, or do I do the easy thing?
He's proud.
If you dry brush Crouching Mode, a heavy kick on him.
I will do that.
Oh,
nice combo!
Yes!
Yes, sir!
Oh, again!
And again!
Just flow!
Let's go!
Oh, in the ground!
One more.
Oh my god!
PSCA, that's about it.
Nice fireball.
Good idea.
Yes, very good recovery.
No, not the sand.
Pocket sand.
Just take it!
That's mine!
Just eat the sandbubble, baby!
Clean play.
Let's go.
All right, I guess there's still a chance we can go to TwitchCon.
Yeah, yeah.
No pressure.
No pressure!
Coach, no pressure!
It's time.
Hell yes.
It's time, brother.
We leave it all to you, coach.
Brian, I have to do a coach match too, man.
I know how you feel.
I'm fucking ready, dude.
Coach match time.
Oh, wait.
I remembered.
I promised I remembered to leave.
Wait, let me not do Honda, though.
I'm not that ready.
Imagine you started off as Honda.
Yeah.
They're just like, sorry, no resets.
Dude, I almost had the trade combo.
He was too far away.
Damn!
It's all that matters is that you won, coach.
That's all that matters.
That's true.
There's nothing about being fancy here.
It's all about winning.
Good job, man.
I'm so proud of you.
Thanks, dude.
I'm proud of you.
Thank you guys for...
Thank you, guys, for carrying.
We will carry our teammates.
We're doing this for SK and for Doki.
I should have trained yesterday, but instead I played Roblox.
That's my bad.
Nah, that's for your sanity and your mental health.
Let's keep it down for coach, though.
Coach, you got this.
Full focus.
Good luck.
Good luck, coach.
Oh, nice pull.
Mix up.
Oh, that's sick.
Nice mash.
Yes.
Catch the delay tech.
Coco.
That's nice.
Nice anti-air.
Let's go.
Burned out.
Get in there.
Checkmate situation.
Checkmate.
Checkmate, baby.
Fucking go.
Let's fucking go, coach.
Let's go, baby.
My coach.
That's my coach right there.
Nice anti-air.
That was good.
Woo.
Almost had it.
Almost, almost.
Okay.
Oh, the mash up.
Ball time.
Fuck it.
We ball, dude.
Let's go.
Stand still.
He hit someone.
Safe jump.
It's all right.
All right.
Yeah.
Give him the corner.
Oh, no way.
What the fuck?
That's insane.
Hold on.
Yeah.
He had the meter.
Hold on.
He had zero bars, though.
If he gets them.
Yes.
Get him.
Checkmate.
Back in the corner.
Go.
Checkmate.
Checkmate, baby.
Oh, the BM.
Oh, my God.
Let's fucking go.
I'm here to fucking play.
My turn, baby.
Let's fucking go.
Kick my hand.
Finally.
Guys, I stand back so we could have a coach match.
Sure.
Lock it in.
Oh, time to go in.
Ooh.
Nice.
Nice anti-air.
Yeah.
Ooh, bait that.
Oh.
Minus six.
Oos.
Oh, drop.
It's okay.
No worries.
American reset.
Oh, don't be.
Oh.
Watch out.
He's dead.
Please.
Oh, he's doing the coaching.
Yeah.
This is...
This is the...
This is yours, right?
Yes.
Oh, but he's out of the corner.
Good.
Yeah.
Worth.
Here we go.
All right.
No worries.
Composure.
Nice.
Come here.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Get in there.
No.
You're bomb.
And then one more interaction after this.
Kind of.
Not really.
Yeah.
Did you hear me?
Get him, coach.
The trademark.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Wait for it.
I'm freaking losing my mind, dude.
What the fuck is that?
I'm losing my mind.
I can't believe what I'm watching.
That was actually so dope.
Yeah.
Blitz.
Oh, no.
She's trying to adapt.
Don't let him do that.
Oh, no.
She's trying to adapt.
Don't let him do that.
All right.
He did this so he can build some drive meter.
Let him fuck.
Yeah.
Let him cook.
Oh, good shimmy.
That was good.
I'll give it to him.
Yeah.
That was a good shimmy.
Well played.
Oh.
Oh, he didn't go for the kill?
Oh, he's burnt out.
That's why.
Oh, that was close.
You could have got that.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Just parries.
Come here.
Okay.
Heads up.
Oh.
He got hit.
Stand still.
Oh, that's okay.
Okay.
He's bent out.
Oh, the shimmy.
Nice.
Come on.
He got hit.
Stand still.
Oh, that's okay.
Yeah, that's death.
Nice conversion.
We got this.
Let's go coach.
Full focus.
Avenge us.
We believe.
Good job chat.
Send all the energy.
Nice.
What the fuck?
That was insane.
Anti everything.
And another anti.
Anti.
Everybody...
is just so far away from each other.
Nice.
Nice grab.
Nice grab again.
Oh yeah.
The meaties.
I don't think this is going to kill though.
Unless.
Unless he.
Oh my gosh.
Just block it out.
Nothing to worry about.
Nice.
Blocked it out.
Good.
Nice.
That was so good.
Collected.
Oh my god the defense.
Just keep it cool man.
This is what it looks like when you block.
Yes.
Oh empty jump.
Fucking rebound.
Who is Brian?
Brian is for the blind.
He is the vision for the hungry.
He is the chef for the thirsty.
He is the one.
If Brian thinks I agree.
Oh.
Oh nice.
Yes sir.
Get in there.
Keep it cool.
Oh.
That is so close.
Let's go.
Let's do this.
Last game.
Last round.
It is intense right now dude.
Get him.
You are mine.
Mmm.
Yes.
Stand still.
Let's go.
God that is so cool dude.
Oh yeah baby.
Fucking we both.
You are mine.
Let's fucking go.
We are going to fucking flip.
That's right baby.
Let's fucking do this.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Let's go baby.
I can't believe it.
G.
Fucking G.
What a match to end on.
Oh my god.
You are so good.
That is crazy.
Let's go baby.
Let the coach fucking flip.
I couldn't close my eyes.
I was just listening.
Good job coach.
That was awesome.
You did so good.
Oh my god.
That was intense.
We believed in the coach dude.
We believed.
I was here.
That was too intense.
Oh my goodness.
That was so good.
Good job guys.
I can't believe we ended on a coach match.
SK Doki we got this.
We did it.
Thank you for the carry guys.
Everybody.
We did.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah dude.
Let's finish for it.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Now fight to see who the real diaphone is.
Now you know I'm getting a little tired.
You know.
It's 7 o'clock you know.
I don't know.
It's past my bedtime.
You did a hard day's work coach.
Good shit.
Well played everybody.
Good job guys.
Good job for winning for us.
Let's go.
See you at TwitchCon.
Maybe.
I put everything on day 2.
So we're for sure done for real right?
We're done for the day.
Yeah we're done for real.
It's just the finals now.
Now it's just Winners Finals.
We'll get to see who's in Grand Finals.
Yeah GG's everybody.
GG's.
I don't think I'm gonna watch.
I'm not gonna watch Winners Finals.
I'm just gonna chill now.
I'm fucking stressed.
You're heading out Doki?
Yeah I'm heading out.
Bye bye.
If you guys wanna watch Winners Finals go to Twitch.
And watch SageM.
Or like anyone that's still out round.
And we're putting the bird to rest.
Are the rest of you guys chilling here?
Yeah I'm gonna be chilling.
GG's guys.
I'm just gonna be chilling in this chat.
I need to de-stress with GG's everybody.
Yeah GG Doki.
Good stuff Doki.
Thanks for the insane gameplay.
Insane gameplay.
Bye bye guys.
Bye bye.
Talk to you later.
See ya.
Alright guys.
As much as I wanna hang out.
I'm fucking stressed.
I need a vibe.
I need...
Those games...
Fucked me up.
I need to like...
De-stress right now and just sleep.
Cause like... I know I slept a lot.
But it's like...
These games actually fucked me up.
So...
I need to rest now.
And mentally reset myself.
I definitely...
Should have trained more yesterday.
Because like...
The only training I got was...
With Justin last night.
And like...
I definitely did not adapt in time.
Cause like...
I knew people were labbing me.
But I didn't...
Like when people labbed me I was like...
I don't know what to change.
Cause I'm like...
I don't... I don't know.
Cause like...
I think my main strategy was like...
If they jump...
I just do that.
But then everybody like...
Stopped jumping towards me.
Everybody would jump away from me.
And then everyone did like anti-airs too.
So I was like...
Oh no...
I was just like...
What do I do?
That's all my moves.
Like...
I was like...
That's all my moves.
Anti-air.
And then...
Like I...
But then they anti-aired me.
So I was just like...
What do I do?
But...
The way I used to hit.
I was like...
Okay...
I will hit twice.
I'm so right.
I'm just gonna die...
What do I do now?
Yeah, I'm just... all the matches were incredibly close, though.
Incredibly close.
I don't know if I crumbled or anything.
I definitely overthought a lot.
But I definitely should have played more last night.
I should have played more last night.
Because I played for two hours today.
Two to three hours today before the stream.
Before the tournament.
But that was definitely not enough.
Because I went for more so ARS PD.
Because everybody was doing jumping.
So I didn't know.
Because usually you jump.
That's normal.
When you fight people, it's normal that people jump.
But it threw me off when people stopped jumping.
I was like, the fuck?
I was like, why did you stop jumping?
It threw me off.
Yeah, and the whole... they were doing moves I've never seen before.
Because I wasn't used to it.
But I'm going to try.
I'm glad my team carried me for today.
Like, I got my teams back last night.
Not last night.
Sorry, two days ago.
And then my team carried me through today.
Which is great.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah.
They...
Yeah, everybody.
I think for me...
I don't know about... I don't know.
It depends on like...
Because some of us are going to keep playing FGC.
Like, fighting games in the future.
I usually join whenever I get invited to tournaments.
Because I don't want to... I don't want to be up a tier.
I don't want to be up a tier.
I just want to play in beginner tier.
And I also like...
Fighting games stress me out so much.
Like, it might not seem like it.
Like...
But like...
The back-to-back-to-back Street Fighter shit...
Fucked me up.
It was so stressful.
Like, because I...
That's why yesterday I didn't train.
I didn't train because like...
I was like...
I was just way too stressed out.
I was just like...
I was just so out of it at that point.
Because I felt like...
I played...
Because it was like...
You gotta learn.
Especially as a beginner.
You have to learn so fast.
At such a short amount of time.
And...
It's similar to Tekken.
Tekken like...
Tekken...
The vibes was more like...
Less serious.
The Street Fighter vibes was so serious.
And like...
I also have a million things going on behind the scenes too.
So like...
Street Fighter...
Just like...
I think like...
During the finals...
It just piled on to me.
And then I got like...
Super stressed out and nervous too.
And...
I just need like...
I just think like...
The more I vibe...
The better I do.
Because...
Day 2...
I vibed.
Today...
I was half vibing.
Because like...
During the Bison match...
It was...
I think...
I definitely cracked under the pressure.
Because everybody stopped talking and got super focused on me.
And then...
I started being super like...
Stressed out.
So like...
That's something...
Something like...
Like I learned about myself.
Because I didn't notice that in Tekken.
Like the one time that happened to me was against...
The match against Gumi.
During Tekken...
Like the first game during finals.
That happened to me.
But then I didn't realize it was like...
Oh because I wasn't...
I was just thinking too much.
But now...
I learned that like...
If everybody's too serious...
If everybody is too serious...
I just don't know what to do.
I just do...
I just...
I just don't know what to do...
When everybody is way too serious.
Because I realized...
Wait.
When we were talking about Overwatch...
Like I was doing really well.
Because I wasn't thinking.
And I was just doing what I'm used to doing.
And...
When...
I do better when I'm reacting.
That's for sure.
Than...
Thinking up a game plan.
No way.
But yeah.
Yeah.
It's more so like...
Oh man.
It's...
It's easier for me to react than it is to have a game plan.
Because like...
I start...
I start like being like...
What the fuck do I do?
Next time...
If I ever...
I don't know about doing any...
I don't know.
I don't know about getting a bite again for a time.
But like...
Depends on the game.
If I'm put above beginner...
I'm not gonna...
I'm really way too stressed out as a beginner.
So like...
If I'm put above my tier...
I'm not doing it.
And it depends on the team.
And the team vibe.
I don't like...
I even...
During...
The...
During the thing with...
Sajam.
When I...
When they asked me what kind of team I want.
I literally said like...
I don't...
I don't care about winning.
I just...
Want...
You know...
A team that vibes.
Like I literally...
That's what I told Sajam.
I was like...
Don't...
Don't put me a team that's super serious.
Like I...
Don't fuck with that.
Like...
I...
I was just like...
Don't put me a team that just...
Is here to just win and nothing else.
Like I was like...
I...
I just want a vibe team.
Like that's literally all I want.
Like...
Cause I was like...
I don't care.
I just wanna have fun.
Like I don't...
I don't...
I don't care about...
Like...
Winning.
I just wanna have fun.
Like...
I don't want them to make me...
Train for 10 hours a day.
I don't wanna...
So...
Um...
I'm glad the vibes...
Were...
Reset itself...
After that second match.
Cause that second match was so stressful.
Like...
Everybody...
Was so serious.
And I don't even know if I should talk anymore.
Because everybody was so serious.
Um...
So I'm glad that...
That...
The vibe softened up.
For...
Day...
Like this third match.
Uh...
For the third match.
Yeah.
I'm glad the vibe...
And then I had to have a mental reset there.
Uh...
Yeah.
The pressure.
Ah...
That's what happens for your tournaments.
I'm glad that...
Matman...
Uh...
Came to help too.
For...
Uh...
Cause Mat...
Mat...
Like messaged Brawl Pro too.
To be like...
Yeah.
Like...
Softened up the vibe.
Make it...
Make it less stressful.
And stuff.
Very jokey.
So I really appreciate that too.
And...
Uh...
Oh my god though.
Watching that JP match.
Against Brawl Pro.
I was mad.
I was like...
This is fucking stupid.
Like...
I didn't say much.
But like...
Watching that match up.
I was like...
This is fucking stupid.
Like ban this character.
Like...
I was like...
This should take the meter.
This is so fucking stupid.
Like...
I was like...
Bro...
Like...
This is so...
I was like...
If I had to play that...
I would just forfeit.
Like...
I don't care.
If anybody actually counter...
Counterpicked me...
And played JP...
I literally would just...
Play one round.
See that shit.
And I'm like...
I'm sorry guys.
I'm forfeiting.
Like...
I...
This is...
So fucking stupid.
Like...
I wasn't having fun watching that.
And I wasn't even playing.
I felt the fucking tilt.
Like...
This is...
I'm so...
Yeah...
I...
Um...
Yeah...
Like...
Get me...
I was like...
I don't even want to watch this anymore.
Like...
Jesus...
Yeah...
I was like...
I don't even want to fucking watch this.
Like...
This isn't even fun to watch.
I was on that JP's team.
I don't even want to have fun watching this game.
Cause I would just hate you.
Like...
Hahaha...
Yeah...
Haha...
But...
It was a good learning experience.
Um...
I'm glad...
Like...
I helped the team out on day one and two.
And then my team...
Um...
My team backed me up on...
Uh...
Day three.
I'm sorry, guys.
I didn't win my keep matches in the finals.
I'm sorry.
I know I should have practiced more.
But like...
I played for the vibes.
Hahaha...
I mean...
I...
I know I should have not played.
Like...
Roblox yesterday.
But like...
I couldn't, guys.
Like...
I...
I swear.
If I had to play more Street Fighter yesterday.
If I had to like...
Like...
Not play more...
If I had to like...
Grind out Street Fighter even more yesterday.
I was so fucking done.
Like...
Hahaha...
I needed that...
I needed that mental reset.
Like...
Hahaha...
I really needed that mental reset.
Like...
Hahaha...
I...
Like...
Um...
Cause like...
Two hours before the stream.
Um...
Two hours before today's stream.
I did the custom room.
I did a custom room.
And I was just like...
I'm so...
I can't...
I'm so done.
Hahaha...
I was just like...
I was...
Cause I've been fighting the same...
You know?
Cause you're just...
I...
I was just like...
Oh my god.
Like...
Like seeing the same moves over and over again.
And I'm just like...
Oh my god.
Hahaha...
I was just like...
Blank of all...
Blank of...
Slide...
Blank of all...
Kick...
And I was just like...
I'm going crazy.
I'm gonna fucking go crazy.
Hahaha...
I was like...
I'm gonna go fucking...
I'm gonna go nuclear.
Hahaha...
Yeah...
Um...
They were all really...
Uh...
Really...
Close matches.
They were all really close matches.
They had...
The enemies adapted really, really well to me.
And I couldn't adapt in time.
But I think I...
I basically...
I...
Uh...
I took all the matches to like...
The dot.
Like...
The fact that all of them...
Uh...
Um...
The fact that all of them...
Labbed hours.
Or like...
Studied how I played.
And everything.
And like...
Changed up their playstyle.
That...
I thought...
That was very impressive.
Everybody changed their playstyle just to fight me.
Like...
They had the same playstyle for everybody else.
And then everybody I fought changed the way they played.
Like...
I...
I couldn't change the way I play in time for that.
Yeah...
Um...
So...
That's why I was like...
Like...
That's why that...
That threw me off.
Hahaha...
They all changed the way they played.
Uh...
So I...
That threw me off too.
Um...
Cause they knew I was really good at anti-air.
So they stopped jumping.
And then...
And they stopped doing air stuff.
Like...
Jumping stuff.
And then...
They played so passively.
So I was just like...
Oh my god.
I never studied that.
Yeah...
Uh...
But in the end...
My team clutched it out.
So...
Um...
Hahaha...
My team...
My team clutched it out.
Everybody played differently.
But...
Doesn't matter.
They all...
They all lapped against me.
But it doesn't matter.
They...
Fuck...
Our team still got to TwitchCon.
So...
Hahaha...
Like...
They all...
It doesn't matter.
In the end...
We all still go to TwitchCon.
So like...
Who the fuck cares?
Like...
Hahaha...
Whatever.
Like...
Hahaha...
I do wish I did perform better.
I do...
Um...
Cause everybody...
That's also the thing.
A lot of people put...
So much expectation over me.
Because I 5-0'd.
Um...
Because I...
5-0'd...
On day 2.
So a lot of people put like...
A lot of respect to me.
I was like...
Please don't.
Like...
Hahaha...
I was like...
Please...
Don't do that to me.
Hahaha...
I was like...
Please...
I...
I don't...
I like being the underdog.
Please...
Um...
Ah...
Yeah, but...
Yeah!
Anyway.
Ah...
Um...
It was great.
GG to team Brian.
To the...
Rest of...
Um...
To the rest of my team.
SK Brian Brawl Pro Coefficient.
Especially for everybody for...
Putting me in the backpack.
So...
So I can just chill like right after.
I was nervous.
I was so nervous today just because I knew how much pressure I had like day two.
I had zero pressure.
Day three, I had so much pressure and expectation.
So like I was just that made me so nervous.
But it was a good learning experience in the end.
I had I was just here vibing.
So I hope you guys enjoyed the Sajam Slam.
Another Sajam Slam arc for Street Fighter.
For those who are wondering what's gonna happen at TwitchCon, you'll find out at TwitchCon.
So just watch that.
Just watch the TwitchCon Sajam Slam stream to see what they're gonna do to me.
Like what's funny is that Team Shine is gonna replace half their roster.
So I don't fucking know what the fuck is gonna happen to that roster.
So like like Team Shine literally has to replace half their roster to so like I don't know.
Like I don't know what they're gonna do there.
So like whoever's gonna be on Team Shine is just gonna be an entirely different team.
Which I assume it's gonna have because it's their first two.
So I assume that it's either Daya and Daya and Otto's team.
So either Saikuno or Saikuno.
Who is it?
Daya... J... Otto's team got knocked out.
So who's in... Who's Otto's first first seed?
First seed?
Seratina?
So either Daya or Seratina.
Oh sorry sorry.
Seratina or Saikuno are just gonna replace uh it's gonna replace uh um Shine's first first seed.
And then I guess who's the second seed?
I don't remember whose second seed is.
Group B... Group B uh group B.
Where's Group B?
And then... Not B sorry C.
And then it's gonna be either Cat or Cat or Amour replacing their second.
So... Wait what is Umi calling me about?
Hello?
Can you mod me?
Is that why you called me?
No I want to ask are you calling me?
Are you really not going to TwitchCon?
Well, I'm not gonna say it to people or they're gonna try and find me, Gumi.
This is why I don't say if I'm going anywhere.
Well, I DM'd you and you never told me so I thought I would have to call you so you'd finally give me an answer.
I won't tell, I won't snitch!
I'm on stream!
Damn it!
I'm not gonna fucking say if I'm going or not if I'm streaming, Gumi!
Oh my god, oh my god, that's why I'm asking you to just type it!
That's why I'm asking you to type it, man!
Okay.
I see!
That's cool.
Chat, she just typed lol at me.
Yeah, lol, lol.
I just said lmao.
Are you watching?
I'm not watching the games, by the way.
Are you watching the last finals?
I'm just vibing with my chat.
I'm so honest.
I got so tired after waiting to play my next game for two hours.
Girl, I was so stressed out.
It was...
I'm tired.
That's why I was like, I wasn't watching it because I was like, I'm too tired to keep going.
I just wanna vibe.
I don't wanna talk more.
I'm also tired.
No, I don't wanna talk more.
I just don't wanna talk more Street Fighter.
I'm so... I'm tired.
I'm tired.
Did you see my costume?
Yeah, I did.
They were posting the picture.
Yeah.
And you changed your playstyle.
It fucked with me.
You were so passive.
Oh, yeah.
Um...
I... it's because I'm so used to like, you know in Tekken?
Yeah.
Where it's like, if you lose your turn, you just need to get it back.
In my head, I was like, I have to be aggro all the time or else...
Yeah, yeah.
I played as if you were gonna be aggro.
And then you were so passive.
It like, fucked with me.
Because I was like, what are you doing?
I was just looking at you.
I was like, are you gonna move?
I know.
Yeah, so I was just like... so...
Yeah, no.
Like, everybody changed the way they played against me.
Yeah, you're like, everyone's off.
I was just like... no, everyone was so passive.
I didn't know how to deal with that.
I think it's because they realized I don't know how to play against passive players.
Against Seratina.
So everybody found out that passiveness fucks me up.
Oh, I didn't... I think I had to just play passive in general.
My coach told me...
Wait, I should tell you this.
What?
I'm no longer gonna tell me what my coach told me.
No, tell me.
Tell me.
No.
I'm gonna play the same way.
If I go to TwitchCon.
I mean, you should tell me.
It's a 50-50 if I'm there or not.
No.
Because you said I couldn't sleep on the bed with you.
Yeah.
I mean, if you tell me, maybe I'll change my mind.
Really?
You mean it?
Tell me.
Anyways, my coach just told me to keep jumping.
To keep jumping?
You didn't jump a lot, though.
Yeah, because you didn't do your weird bald-headed smudge or something.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, no, but like...
I was waiting for you to jump at me, but you didn't do that either.
Yeah, no.
I was like, man, everyone's probably...
I only do like three moves, man.
No, yeah, but you...
You like slowed down the entire game.
So I was just like, why do I...
Like, who's gonna go first?
But it's alright.
Both of our teams are going to TwitchCon.
Let's fucking go.
I know.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, I'm so tired.
Have you been tired just learning Street Fighter for like the past week?
Do you want to know how many hours I have in Street Fighter?
How many hours?
23 and half of it was just on the waiting menu.
Is that like how much you could... like, were you just done after that?
Or were you just like...
Like, I think...
Personally...
I can't play fighting games for too long or else my hands hurt.
Oh, yeah, I saw... yeah, I heard about that, yeah.
Because I know like in Tekken you grinded a lot, though.
Yeah, and look at what happened to my hands.
Yeah, and then your hands.
You fucked up your hands after Tekken.
I actually had calluses forming on my thumbs and stuff.
Oh my god, that's fucking crazy.
Holy shit.
Yeah, and Street Fighter is my first time playing on a level list.
Yeah.
And sometimes I do be looking down.
I'm like, what key am I pressing?
Yeah, me too.
Me too.
Yeah.
I couldn't play too much Street Fighter because I'd just get burned out or mad.
I know!
That's why I don't play Rank.
Do you know what?
Rank is a real friendship.
As soon as I got Heartstuck Silver for like six plus hours...
I just stopped playing Rank and just made custom lobbies against viewers.
Because I was like, I can't.
This is making me too angry.
I think like in the past, I would say the Rank Confederate games that made me the most angry was Splatoon.
Because you can't voice chat and yell at your teammates too.
You can't like yell at people if they're fucking bad.
And you can't avoid them too.
So like, Splatoon Rank was terrible.
And it actually made me like yell at my TV and like throw my controller.
Because I was so angry.
No, I feel like that's how like...
I think Overwatch...
Overwatch is fine for me.
No, no.
When there's terrible players, I feel like I become a different person.
You know?
No, that's true too.
But then like, I've never...
But never in my life has a Rank game like Street Fighter overpowered my hate of Splatoon Rank.
Street Fighter... like Tekken Rank, I was fine.
I enjoyed Tekken Rank.
Street Fighter Rank, oh my god.
Like, it actually made me so angry.
Kidding?
I genuinely don't care about Rank, which is why I never moved past Iron.
I just haven't played a Ranked game since that week.
Yeah.
The first day of Siege M7, because like...
I don't care about hitting a high Rank.
And not only that, it's like...
You kind of just don't know...
I don't like playing against someone and them seeing me play like while trying to figure it out.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's true too.
I wish like...
I...
I kept asking...
I felt bad asking people to not stream my coaching session.
Because like...
Like I know like the mo...
Like they're all like watching my coaching session VODs too.
But like...
I felt bad because they're like...
They need content.
Johnny, I want you to know I ain't watched shit.
I did zero...
No, no.
I know like some people actually watched my coaching sessions.
Even when I don't stream.
People were like...
Some of the beginners were watching like how I was being coached.
When I was being coached by others.
So like...
Or like the other coaches were watching it and telling them what they were being taught.
That shit like...
I was...
That shit like fucked me up.
I was like...
No!
Stop watching me!
Stop!
Because like when I played Tekken for King.
I requested Brawl Pro to not stream my coach matches.
Because like...
I was also like...
I was like...
I...
I just want to vibe.
Like I want to be chill.
And I don't want to like...
I don't like really want to be like judged for...
Like I don't want people to analyze me because I don't know what I'm doing.
But like for Street Fighter.
I was like...
Okay.
Obviously like...
Content.
So like...
I was like...
I was okay with letting coaches stream the practices.
The first...
I remember like the first practice.
I was like...
I don't want...
Oh can we like...
Can I do it off stream?
And then...
But then the coach was like...
I need to sleep.
So I was like...
Okay.
Can you coach me after your stream?
But then he's like...
I need to sleep.
So I was like...
Okay.
It's okay.
I'll be there.
So I'll be there when you wake up.
Yeah.
But yeah.
I don't know.
I feel bad.
My coach...
Literally sent a message into our team chat.
I was like...
Guys.
I want to at least get an hour a day of coaching with everyone.
Every single day.
Yeah.
If possible, please do that.
And...
I don't know.
I think I only showed up for the first day.
Oh my god.
I did zero training.
That's funny.
It's just like...
I don't know.
Because I feel like if I get too into it, I'll stress out too much.
Yeah.
Like...
That's what happened to me.
Yeah.
After like day two.
Like day two.
There was just so much pressure too.
Because I 5-0'd.
So then I was like...
Oh no.
Now it's not just 5s.
I was just like...
Oh no.
Now I actually have to...
But then like...
On the other hand, I was like...
I'm too burnt out right now.
I need a mental reset.
So then I just...
My mental reset won overall.
Instead of like...
Trying to...
Train.
No.
I felt that.
Like...
On the first day...
You and I both tied 3-2.
For like...
Our bracket.
And I was the only person who went positive on my team.
Yeah.
And everyone was so down in the dumps.
In team chat.
Yeah.
But they were like...
But you did really good, Gumi.
And I felt like this pressure.
I was like...
Oh my god.
Does this mean I have to do well next time?
And like...
You know...
Day 2...
I was kind of...
Gone.
Yeah.
And then...
I went 0-5.
1 and 4 only because Lily's internet went out.
Yeah.
But I went 0-5 and I was like...
Oh my god.
What the fuck.
And then...
Today I just said...
Fuck it.
I'm wearing a Blanka costume.
You're just like...
I'm vibing.
Yeah.
I can't even see properly with this shit on.
I feel like...
Like...
I just...
I just want to vibe.
That's really it.
Like...
Um...
Cause like...
This is a pretty fun tournament too.
So it's more so of like...
Your progress overall.
Like...
Yeah.
And I think...
We both improved so much too.
Like...
None of us...
Both of us don't play Street Fighter.
And then like...
Both of us don't play fighting games in general.
Yeah.
We don't play fighting games.
We're variety streamers.
And we both did pretty...
Pretty well.
So...
We could definitely be like...
Obviously...
We could...
Do really, really well.
But it's also like...
I just...
I just want to chill sometimes.
Oh my god.
This isn't for fun.
You're right.
There is money on the line, isn't it?
There is money on the line.
Yeah.
That's like...
You know.
People can worry about that at TwitchCon.
Yeah.
Me, personally.
I'm...
I don't know.
Don't tell no one.
But I'm still not training.
I want you to know the most training I do.
But were you still not training?
Yeah.
No.
That's...
Like...
Why would I?
What am I gonna change?
I just feel like...
I feel like...
If you try too hard to...
Like...
Yeah.
It's not just gonna...
It's gonna hurt even more when you lose.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's like...
I...
Cause I knew.
I knew.
I was like...
Okay.
I'm not gonna be training.
So then I was just like...
Okay.
Like...
If I lose, it's whatever.
If I lose, I know why I lost.
Like...
Yeah.
I was like...
I know why I lost.
Like...
I know why.
Cause I didn't train.
Like...
I think you and I are the same.
I knew people were gonna start...
Labbing me.
But I still...
I kept at it.
Like...
Cause like...
I knew I was like...
I think you and I are the same.
Where we both like...
We don't care how our teams do.
As long as we do fine.
Yeah.
But yeah.
I get what you mean.
Yeah.
Cause I was just like...
I was just...
I...
I knew I was just...
If I...
Kept going at it yesterday...
I...
Mentally...
I would just be out.
Like...
I...
I was...
Mentally...
I was just...
Not...
Not there.
Cause like...
Even...
Two hours...
Two to three hours before...
Uh...
Before the...
The...
The tournament...
Um...
I was...
That...
That close.
Mentally.
Like...
Oh my god.
Cause I really...
I...
Uh...
I really...
I really was like...
I...
I needed more rest days...
In between.
Um...
I needed more...
Rest days in between.
Cause like...
Even like...
I was...
Fighting viewers...
And I was just...
Not having fun.
I was like...
Just...
It felt like I was just...
In a cog...
In the machine.
And I felt like...
If I had two rest days...
I would be fine.
But the fact that it was like...
Just one...
But then like...
Everybody was using that one...
To hard grind too...
And...
Um...
And then...
Go straight into like...
In the...
The finals.
Like...
I feel like...
I felt like round one...
Round two...
And then...
Round three...
Was just too much.
Like...
With one day in between...
It was just...
Too much for me.
I definitely needed...
Needed like...
More than one day.
Cause I need that one day...
To reset myself...
And then the second day...
To train again.
And like um...
I talked about this...
But like...
I really like...
Sagem Slam.
I think it's so fun...
To be a part of.
It's just a...
It's a lot...
For the beginners...
Where...
You're learning a whole new game...
Yeah...
Right off the bat...
And like...
You have to train non-stop...
And try to get like...
At a decent level...
Within one week...
While also participating...
In the round robin days...
Yeah...
Somebody was saying like...
I should...
Join a less serious tournament...
We didn't know there was prize money...
Until we got...
Accepted...
And then teams were out...
Yeah...
We didn't know there was prize money involved...
We literally found out...
After...
The whole system...
Like...
Everything was established...
And then...
Uh...
Cause we thought it was...
The previous...
Sajam slams...
Had no prize money involved...
Yeah...
It was like...
For fun type deal...
And like...
Prize money...
Got added in...
At the last...
Minute...
Before like...
Uh...
So like...
If I knew that...
It was that serious...
I also wouldn't participate...
Because like...
The fact that like...
Car...
Like...
A lot of money...
Is involved too...
So like...
I felt like...
I wouldn't say I wouldn't participate...
But I would have changed my mindset...
Going in...
Oh yeah...
Like...
Well...
If I knew it was like...
Lots of money involved...
I would have...
Changed my mindset...
Going into this tournament...
Um...
Sorry...
He's like...
Madge...
So yeah...
Like...
I didn't know...
Gumi...
Like...
None of us knew...
There was prize money...
Until...
Everything...
Everybody was in...
Teams were already established...
Uh...
And then they announced that...
There was a 50k...
Prize money...
I mean...
I knew there was...
50k prize money...
I'd be like...
Seija...
Put me in the best team...
No...
I'm joking...
I would have done...
Put a team together...
Uh...
Nephew...
Me...
Um...
Can we somehow include...
The other coaches...
On my team...
I'd be like...
Hey...
I like to have...
Who's the highest ranked coach...
I would like to request...
For that coach...
I literally...
Request...
Brian...
Because...
People were telling me...
Brian was like...
Vibey...
And he didn't take it...
Super seriously...
So like...
That's why I requested...
Brian...
I was just like...
I wanted a coach that vibes...
And...
People were telling me...
Like...
It was either Daya...
Or Brian...
That were like...
Super vibey...
So then I was like...
Okay...
I'll...
I'll get...
Brian...
Then...
Um...
And then Daya was like...
My...
Uh...
My second choice...
Oh...
Mine was...
Um...
Nephew...
Because I...
Got coached by him...
Before the...
Slam...
Even like...
Started...
And then...
The other one was JB...
Just because I liked his Discord icon...
That's funny...
Like...
I did zero research...
I...
It's because I was going to play Juri...
But then Seijum said...
Oh yeah...
The yo...
The most Yoshimitsu-like character...
In Street Fighter...
Is probably Blanka...
And then I just swapped...
Immediately...
Yeah...
And Blanka was like...
My counter pick...
For Gief...
Like...
It...
Apparently...
Blanka and Lily...
Were both like...
Hard to count...
Like...
Hard to play against...
For Gief...
Uh...
I don't know...
Man...
I just...
That's what I was told...
That was...
One of the hardest matchups...
Because you guys have range...
I just like the way Blanka shakes ass...
But yeah...
Like...
It was a good experience...
I don't...
I don't know...
Like...
Uh...
I...
I don't...
I don't know...
Like...
For like...
I think people should know...
For me...
That...
I do these tournaments...
Not...
To like...
Not like...
Not saying...
Oh...
Not to win...
But like...
I do these tournaments...
To have fun...
Especially games that like...
I don't play...
And...
I had fun...
In the end...
Um...
I like meeting new people...
Sometimes...
I know like...
I said like...
I...
Was scared of meeting new people...
Um...
But...
When you do end up meeting new people...
And if you vibe with them...
Then it's always a good time...
Um...
Yeah...
And like...
I know like...
People are like...
Oh...
You...
You needed to be like...
Super tri-high...
For your team...
And everything...
Um...
I did...
I...
I learned a lot...
For the first two days...
But I knew that...
For me...
I had to like...
Mentally reset myself...
Before the finals...
Because at that point...
I was like...
Mad...
And like...
Tired...
And...
Felt like a cog in the machine...
Yeah...
Sorry...
My dog is...
He wants food...
I'm gonna feed him...
After this stream...
Wait...
Oh...
Kazi almost needs food too...
Yeah...
It's almost his feeding time...
Did you have fun...
Gumi?
I'll be so honest with you...
The most coaching I've done...
Is...
Like...
30 minutes before...
Each training day...
Like...
They just say...
Gumi...
I'm going to want you to...
Look at this...
Do this...
And I'm like...
Okay...
And then I do it...
And that's it...
I'll let him in...
Because he's gonna...
He just wants to...
Hang out for a little bit...
Alright...
What do you want?
Aw...
Nice...
As long as you didn't...
Burn yourself out...
That's...
I know...
I'm doing literally...
The opposite...
That's good...
Because like...
During Tekken...
I didn't...
I don't think I trained...
That much for Tekken...
Um...
I just played rank...
Most of the time...
And just did the same combos...
Over and over again...
I trained...
More...
For...
This...
Than I did for Tekken...
Because it was so much more serious...
Because of the money too...
Um...
But then like...
You know...
Like...
At that point...
On the third...
That's...
The day before the finals...
I was like...
I can't keep training anymore...
Yeah...
Like...
You know...
My team and I were joking about a script...
But did you know...
Yeah...
The way our matches went...
How?
This one...
Went the exact same way...
As last...
Um...
Slam...
Oh...
Where I won the first day...
You won the second day...
And I won on the third day...
That's funny...
It's like...
Where Romeo and Juliet...
Fated to be...
We can't be on the same team...
Because we're always in the beginner...
I know...
Unless you're playing...
Unless you want to play a division update...
I know...
Let's...
Let's ask Seijam to make a Splatoon tournament...
No...
I can't...
I cannot do that...
I...
I'd cry...
I think...
I think most likely the next tournament...
Would probably be...
Or like...
I'm pretty sure Seijam's gonna host a 2xKO tournament...
I'm pretty sure...
He's gonna...
Yeah...
I heard from...
Uh...
I heard...
Okay...
I should...
No leaks...
Nevermind...
Um...
I don't know...
It's like up in the air...
It's up in the air...
It's like...
Uh...
I don't know if I want to do 2xKO...
I tried it...
Oh yeah...
I tried it too...
Uh...
Yeah...
I tried it at EVO...
Um...
Yeah...
And that was pretty fun...
And I...
What if we can duo together?
You want to tag in?
Tag team?
Yeah...
For Sajam Slam?
For Sajam Slam...
Yeah...
I said like...
Um...
I don't know...
Like...
I don't...
Cause like...
Depends on like...
Who's in it too...
Cause like I said like...
If a lot of...
Yeah...
I...
I don't want to be put on a team that's...
I said totally this in my chat but I don't want to be put on a team that's like super serious and that...
Like...
I just don't want a super duper serious team...
Um...
Yeah...
So it really depends if...
I know...
Who's...
Gonna be joining...
Because like...
Um...
I know like there were people...
That was supposed to be in this Sajam Slam that dropped out because they were like...
Oh...
I don't...
Know...
I don't know who's like...
I don't know these people so I'm gonna drop out...
Like...
They're like...
I don't know if they're...
We're gonna have the vibes...
So like...
It just depends...
Honestly...
On like...
Who's gonna be in the next Sajam Slam...
That depends...
If I'm gonna be joining the next one...
Yeah...
I...
I get...
I get what you mean because...
I don't know...
I...
I can't...
I don't think in any tournament ever I want to be on a team that's too try-hard and like...
Yeah...
Would get genuinely upset if you didn't do well...
That's what I'm also scared of...
I don't want to...
People to be upset at me...
I don't want...
Me...
Yeah...
Like...
If...
Cause like...
Today...
When I was playing...
When...
When everybody got quiet and serious...
It...
It made me like...
More nervous...
Too...
So like...
I...
I just didn't like that...
Like...
I didn't like...
Those types of vibes...
And then like...
After I said like...
Oh I don't like that...
Then people...
They're all like...
Okay...
Well...
Then everybody started relaxing a lot more...
Which was nice...
Oh...
Cause I was like...
I should...
I was like...
I cannot deal...
I cannot play like that...
Like...
And then it was nice...
The people have started...
Uh...
Being more relaxed about it...
And...
Like...
You know...
Crack...
Like not...
Uh...
Like...
Making it more relaxed...
And more...
Uh...
Lighthearted...
Like...
It felt like...
Less...
Uh...
Pressure in general...
To perform better...
Um...
Yeah...
And then Ko fucking...
Got blasted...
To like...
Loosen up the vibes...
He's like...
This is too...
Too stressful...
After the first...
First matchup...
Ko went...
To get fucking...
Like...
Oh my god...
Relaxed...
In general...
Dude...
To be honest...
That was...
Last night...
I just...
I like...
Drank...
Two bottles of soju...
And...
Oh...
I should've drank last night...
I think that would've helped too...
Girl...
I should've...
I think...
Like...
No...
Yeah...
I...
That's what I didn't do...
Before...
You know how I five...
The day before 5-0...
I got drunk...
I got drunk last night...
So weird...
Weird...
Yeah...
Two zero time...
The day...
Literally...
The day before the finals...
I drank...
Cause I was like...
I can't...
I need to relax...
Cause I was training...
A lot...
The day before the final...
Not final...
The day before...
Round two...
I was training a lot...
And right after training...
I went to...
Drink...
Cause I was like...
I can't...
I...
I need to...
I was like...
I...
I cannot...
I legitimately cannot...
Do this...
So...
I need to relax...
I need...
I need to fucking relax...
Right now...
Yeah...
I still have like...
Two shots of soju in the bottle...
I almost drank...
Yesterday...
I almost...
I was so close...
I was...
Oh my god...
But instead...
I drank a fucking...
San...
Pe...
Pellegrino...
Fucking...
Pellegrino yeah...
San Pelegrino...
Italian sparkling...
I drank that instead...
I was like...
Do I drink...
And now I know where we are...
My hard iced tea...
Or do I drink a San Pelgrino...
And...
I think...
I think we found the answer...
I knew it...
The day before I just need to...
I just...
I need to relax...
Come on...
But our chat had fun.
I'm glad chat had fun in the tournament.
I like just talking and chilling after it's over.
I hope you guys enjoyed just vibing right after, guys.
It was a very stressful tournament in general.
So I just like decompressing right after it.
And hanging out.
I was gonna go take a nap.
Me too.
In the end, the fucking matches are all over.
But I was literally gonna go take a nap.
Because I was like, alright guys, I'm not gonna watch the finals.
I'm gonna nap now.
And then we're just here talking.
It's the tournament.
What did you expect?
Yeah, but the Tekken Sajan Slam was so much more...
It was so chill.
The Tekken one was super...
Super chill.
That's what I expected.
The Tekken one was super fucking chill.
But it was also like...
Like I said, the money was on the line.
So people had to try really hard this time around.
Yeah, it was not 50k.
That's why I was just like...
I needed to change my mindset going in and not have to drink.
Yeah.
I think like literally in the Tekken Sajan Slam, everyone was just hanging out on the call every single day and just vibing.
That's true.
Yeah, it didn't even matter if they were like part of the enemy team or whatever.
I see like people from different teams like in the call and stuff.
I guess, to be fair, they didn't open general chat until the first day of round robin.
Because I guess they didn't know it was locked.
Oh, that's funny.
But I also think that there's just more people who like to vibe.
Like Sean wasn't part of this Slam and Sean was one of the people who like set up those scrim lobbies.
Oh, really?
Oh, that's nice.
I don't think I joined any of like the group.
I know like a lot of people from Tekken.
A lot of people during the Tekken one were just hanging out and the group thing every day.
Even after too.
It was there everybody was just hanging out and just playing with each other.
Or like playing against each other.
Like playing against each other or just like streaming their ranked games and stuff.
Like yeah, like money definitely does like change the whole environment of the tournament.
And like, you know, it's always nice to win prize money and stuff.
But like, oh my god, my fucking heart.
Probably one jackbox party.
Yeah, my fucking heart, man.
I think that's also why like when you win, like, you know, training, I think it definitely affected my training, too, because I think about is like, oh, I need to do well, because like, you know, the my teammates need the money, you know?
Yeah.
And then, like, that's why I needed that mental reset because I can't keep thinking like that.
Like, I was like...
I was like...
Yeah, I get what you mean.
Yeah.
Yeah, I definitely train harder because of it, though, because I was like, oh, I want my team to do really well.
And I want my team to have be able to win more prize money.
Damn.
I don't think I could do that again.
I'm gonna DM you something.
I don't think I can.
Yeah.
I was just like, oh, man.
I...
I can't.
I can't do this.
I can't be so serious.
Alright, I DM you.
What?
Yeah.
But yeah, thinking about the money definitely made the nerves even worse for me, too.
Because the money affects... makes it more stressful and more pressure.
But in the end...
Yeah.
I'm glad my team was able to pull through.
I'm glad both of our teams were able to pull through.
What I messaged you about was the reason why, like, I kind of even forgot there was money on the law.
You still made it.
That's the crazy part.
You guys still made it.
You guys still made it there.
Because I know for sure, like...
Wait, sorry.
This is gonna...
Bo-boat.
Oh, I wish I could say this.
I don't...
Can we say this while getting in trouble?
No, I think we'll get in trouble.
No, I meant the other part about the money part.
Oh, yeah.
No.
We can say that there are some players out there who just do not need the money.
Like, you know, there's some players out there who don't really need...
Who don't really take it as serious.
Because the money is not...
Does not matter to them.
It's like negligible to them.
Yeah.
That's like...
That should cure half the FOMO for you guys.
I tried!
I tried so hard, guys!
I just...
I needed that day.
I had it.
I had to mentally reset myself on that day, guys.
I tried...
I tried so much.
I...
I actually tried so much, guys.
I had to fucking...
I had to rest after.
I was consistent about trying.
Oh, wait.
See?
Jeff fucking talked about it.
Bro.
Wait, where?
Apparently.
Oh, yeah.
Apparently, Seijoo reached about it.
Damn.
He told me that he had to beg Esme to even meet our coach before a round-robin day.
Oh, my god, what?
Holy...
Guys, I'm not sure if I was supposed to say this or not.
I didn't fucking stream like Madden instead of playing Street Fighter, I would have fallen in Street Fighter guys.
I didn't stream other things.
I actually tried.
I feel bad for him though.
It seems like he is trying his best.
Like he... he like in our team chat has talked about how he's been grinding a lot the past couple of days.
But he's also like getting a ton of backseaters in his chat.
Yeah, that's why he went on the... I saw that he streamed on another channel too.
Yeah, you didn't know that?
He had a second channel that he was just streaming that on.
Girl, I don't know.
I don't watch stuff.
It just... it popped up in my... oh wait no it didn't pop up.
It like pop... you know how he has like that purple thing that shows up when you're streaming?
Like you know when somebody's streaming it's like... oh like it has that purple notification.
And then I saw Espam was streaming so I looked at it but it wasn't his channel.
It was like a different channel.
Yeah.
On Discord.
I know the backseat has been really...
Yeah, the backseat has been really bad I heard.
But like I don't pay attention to the chat when...
If I am getting backseated, I don't pay attention to chat while I'm playing.
Yeah, what are... well what are they gonna backseat about me bro?
All I do is Blanka Ball.
Like they're always like head... I always... I saw like one thing a lot and it was like headbutt.
You're always forgetting the headbutt.
And because I see that, I was like... I was just like... oh well.
I'm... the game's over.
Like... I just... I re-chat after my matches are over.
Like after... like in between matches.
So I was like well it's too bad, like game's over.
Yeah.
And then I never headbutted again.
No like... oh man.
It's like when someone tells you, oh you should have done this.
You like keep it in your head and then you start making mistakes because of it.
Yeah, that's why I don't want... I try not to focus on my chat too.
Like if... like if I'm in the game right now.
Because then like... you're not doing the circle.
And then so then now in my head I was like, I'm gonna do circles all the time.
And then I realized that... I think it was the first day.
I realized that I was fucking up because all I kept doing was like what if I just do circle.
And I realized, no I should not be doing that.
Like what am I doing?
Why did I... why did I listen?
Why did I hyper focus on the circle?
But I just listen to what my coaches tell me.
Yeah.
No, I appreciate the coaches that are like...
Okay, you can... they're going to dash in now.
And I'm like, oh, okay, if you say so.
Okay, I'll do the thing.
Okay, I'll jump.
It's like actually ratatouille shit.
Yeah, yeah, it's true, true.
They just have to be the rat and I just need to wear the hat.
Nice.
Me too.
That's actually me as well.
Yeah.
But like I can't have too much...
Too much back seating.
Because like I get overwhelmed.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I told my coach.
I was like, oh, I don't...
I don't want to get...
Overwhelmed.
So I want you to like not give me too much information.
And because like if you give me too much information,
I get really overwhelmed.
So then my coach stopped doing that because I think that was my first game with you two.
It was like I had so much information and then I just...
Oh, yeah.
I couldn't figure out what to do at first.
Because I was like, what do I have?
What buttons?
And also I threw a fucking downloading of mine.
But like it was both of those.
I think I'm so thankful that my coach realized this because all he says now is...
Oh, you can command grab.
But then I listened to him coach my teammates.
Like backseat them.
He's like, oh, you should have shoryuken.
Rising Chidori.
Medium punch down low crouch.
Yeah.
I'm like, what?
That's funny.
I'm thankful to the coaches who do like, you know.
Baby a town for us.
Yeah.
I'm glad too.
I'm glad for the...
Oh, yeah.
I'm very happy about the babying.
Yeah.
They were like circle.
X.
Down triangle.
And I'm like, thank you.
I don't know what I'm...
I don't know what I'm doing.
No.
I was literally pressing all three like punch buttons at once.
We just kept it simple for me.
That's funny.
Oh, my God.
Did you eat dinner yet?
Did you eat dinner?
No, not yet.
I've been eating...
The thing is during Street Fighter.
I've been eating one meal.
Yeah.
Every day.
That's the runner lifestyle.
Yeah.
I've been eating one meal every day because I've just been like grinding Street Fighter.
And then I just get too stressed out.
My Tamagotchi.
Sorry.
Go on.
Yeah.
I got too stressed out that I just...
I wasn't hungry.
So, like, I'd eat like lunch.
Yeah.
At like 2 to 3 p.m.
And then like play Street Fighter.
And then...
And then I've just like...
I'm not hungry.
I drink.
I hydrate.
And then I just go to bed.
Oh, yeah.
But I think...
I think like...
Obviously, now my mind is much more chill now.
So, I can focus on eating again.
Yeah.
But it was a fun experience.
So...
Yeah.
I just had my one meal today.
Which was...
I ordered udon.
You ordered udon?
Oh.
I meant pizza.
Yeah.
I'm going...
Dude, what the...
Fuck.
Fucking stupid.
Can you get a Tamagotchi?
Can you buy one so our Tamagotchis can get married?
No.
Tamagotchi...
God!
It's too much weird.
No.
It's like...
They're so advanced.
Now there's babysitters in Tamagotchi.
So, you can send them to the babysitter when you're streaming.
What?
Yeah.
And then, like...
Girl, I'm playing with mine right now.
Never send real collab boys.
It's just...
I don't have time.
I don't have time to fucking play.
No.
Like, all you do is beat it.
And that's it, bro.
And then they grow up.
It's like...
I'm having a jolly good time.
Thank you.
Whatever.
Like, I don't even want to marry your Tamagotchi anyways.
I'm having a jolly good time.
Oh, god.
Okay.
Well.
I'll message you later tonight.
Alright.
GG's, Gumi.
GG's.
I hope you rest well.
Talk to you later.
And start eating two meals again like me.
What?
No.
I'm on that Brunner lifestyle.
Oh, no.
That's not good.
What?
No.
That's not good.
It's...
I'm on that Brunner lifestyle.
Alright.
I'm gonna...
I'm, like, on East Coast schedule, so I've been sleeping at, like, 11 PM every day.
What?
Yeah.
I'm on East Coast schedule.
Do you know what?
I'll message you the details about it.
Okay.
Yeah.
I was like, what?
Why are you on an East Coast schedule?
Ever since I came back from Florida, I haven't been the same.
Alright.
Go take care of yourself and I'll try to.
Okay.
My Tamagotchi says bye.
Alright.
I'll see you later, Gumi.
Bye-bye.
Say bye to my Tamagotchi.
What the hell?
Bye-bye.
Love you.
Say it back.
Bye.
Alright, guys.
I...
I'm gonna hang up.
She went...
She tried to call me again.
Okay.
Gumi, stop.
I will block you.
I need to say bye.
Hey, guys.
I am gonna...
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Give me a sec, guys.
Okay.
She can't do that again.
Anyway, guys.
I blocked you.
Hey, guys.
I am gonna sleep now.
I was actually gonna sleep right after.
Right after.
Okay.
Oh, I didn't realize I had a long talk.
It was nice talking to Gumi and just chilling.
Great experience.
I really enjoyed it.
Met a lot of new friends.
This next week is a lot.
Not rest week because I actually have a lot of commitments to do for next week.
So we're gonna have to deal with that.
I have like...
I think like a sponsor next week.
And I promised to show up for some collabs.
So it's gonna be busy for next week.
So I hope Sunday I can mental reset by then.
But I do hope you guys enjoy the SageM Slam 3 journey.
A lot of support from you guys.
I really do appreciate it.
And a lot of support even though I didn't win my games today.
I really appreciate you guys supporting me and supporting my team.
I had a fun time.
And I know like...
I know a lot of people expected me to do better.
But it was definitely a learning experience.
And I did choose my...
I did choose my mental reset over hard training for the final day.
And obviously like, you know...
It showed.
But I'm happy that my team...
My team did really well.
And took us to TwitchCon.
So I really appreciate my team.
I really appreciate my team clutching it out for me in the end.
And...
Yeah, like...
I told myself like...
I was like...
I need this.
I need to rest.
I...
I grinded so much pre Street Fighter.
Because I knew...
There's a lot of money online.
And I tried my best.
And that's all that matters.
I tried my best.
And we all had fun.
And that's all that matters.
And I hope you guys had fun too.
As always everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stood up for me...
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
No problem.
She's asking me...